I'D LIKE TO WELCOME YOU TO
THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE -- GUESTS PLEASE
TURN OFF YOUR CELL PHONES
CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE PLEASE
AND -- TODAY BECAUSE WE'RE
CHEN AND -- -- WE'RE GONNA
LIMIT TESTIMONY TO INSTANCES
PER SIDE TWO MINUTES PER
WITNESS ALL OTHER PEOPLE WILL
IDENTIFY THEIR POSITION AND
ORGANIZATION AND WILL START
WE HAVE TO CONSENT COUNTER
ITEMS I WANTED TO MENTION --
YES YOUR SIXTY TWO CENTER
STERN AND A. B. SEVEN FIVE TWO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL WILL
START WITH THE MEMBER COOPER
WELCOME OUR HEROES
-- WELCOME ASSEMBLYMAN AND
HE HAS A. B. ONE TWENTY
SIX -- THIS IS THE AIR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT SO
WELCOME TO OUR MEETING AND
-- YOU GET TO HAVE THE HONOR
OF BEING THE FIRST FIRST
WITNESS AT SENATOR DODD SAID
OR -- SOMEBODY SAID FIRST VICTIM
WAS THAT JUST A JOKE OKAY
I'M IN A GOOD MOOD TODAY
IT'S MY ANNIVERSARY
TODAY THIRTY SIX YEARS
EVERYBODY HAPPY ANNIVERSARY
THIRTY SIX YEARS SO
-- I WISH I WAS HOME
BUT I'M HERE WITH YOU TODAY
-- PAT SAID IT'S OKAY SO
-- WILL START REMEMBER COOPER
YOU HAVE THE FORCE THE SALMON
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURRS
WHEN YOU BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU COULD MAKE A BETTER BILL
SINCE TWENTY TEN CALIFORNIA'S
INVESTED OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT ITCHING
OVER THREE THOUSAND REBATES
ONE OF THE GOALS OF THE CVR
PLEASE HELP CLEAN AIR IN AREAS
THE STATE WITH THE WORST AIR
AFTER TEN YEARS CV RP WITH
THE DATA SUGGESTING THE MAJORITY
OF REBATES -- BEING ISSUED IN
AREAS OF THE STATE WITH SOME
OF THE BEST -- QUALITY NOT THE
WORST IN ORDER TO FOCUS LIMITED
RESOURCES TO THE AREAS OF THE
STATE SUFFERING FROM THE WORST
OR QUALITY AB ONE TWENTY SIX
AIMS TO NARROW THE PROGRAM'S
ELIGIBILITY WHILE BROADENING ITS
REACH ACCORDING THE FRANCHISE
TAX TAX BOARD CALIFORNIA'S
MEDIAN INCOME IS ROUGHLY SEVENTY
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS IN CONTRAST
THE INCOME LIMITS PROPOSED IN AB
TWENTY SIX ARE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR SINGLE
FILERS TWO OR FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR HEAD OF HOUSEHOLD
IN THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
JOINT FILERS ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL INCREASES REBATE LEVELS
BY FIVE HUNDRED FOR LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS INCOME LIMITS TO
SEE THE R. P. WERE PROPOSED BY
MY BILL AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
FOUR ROLL TO THE LEAD DOCTOR
TO THE BUDGET PROCESS IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WITH THE ONE YOU'RE
SUNSET AB SIXTEEN FIFTEEN FROM
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CONTINUE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE INCOME
LIMITS FOR TWO YEARS BUT
EXPIRED AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS YEAR AB SIXTEEN FIFTEEN
ALSO REQUIRED REPORT FROM THE
A. R. B. TO THE LEGISLATURE
ON THE IMPACT OF INCOME LIMITS
WHICH WAS DUE BY DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND WE
STILL HAVE NOT RECEIVED WHAT
THEY THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH ME TO IMPROVE THE BILL
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WITNESSES IN FAVOR PLEASE A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BILL AGAIN WITH THE COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR -- AND I THINK
YOU'RE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
IS REALLY VERY ACCURATE AND
ESPECIALLY WANT TO STRESS THIS
POINT THAT THE DEMAND FOR THE
REBATES IS OUTPACING AVAILABLE
FUNDING SO THE REBATE SHOULD
BE STRUCTURED OFFICIALLY TO
PRODUCE THE MOST BANG FOR STATE
PARKS AND I WOULD ADD TO THAT
-- MAKE THE PROGRAM AS EQUITABLE
AS POSSIBLE AND I THINK THAT'S
THIS BILL GOES IN THAT DIRECTION
OF MAKING THE PROGRAM MORE
EFFECTIVE AND MORE EQUITABLE AND
AS THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THE
INCOME CAPS HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN TERMS OF SAVING MONEY FOR THE
PROGRAM SO THAT SEE THE R. P.
CAN LIVE WITHIN ITS MEANS AND
THE SAME TIME TRYING TO CHANNEL
THAT REBATE MONEY TO THOSE
PEOPLE WHO NEED THE REBATES
THE MOST AND WHOSE DECISION TO
BUY AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE WILL BE
MOST AFFECTED BY GETTING THAT
REBATE SO WE ACTUALLY THINK THE
INCOME CAPS ARE COULD BE LOWERED
FROM WHAT THEY ARE NOW AND
THE A. R. B. WOULD RETAIN THE
AUTHORITY TO INSTITUTE A LOWER
CAP WHICH STATE MAY NEED TO DO
-- AND ALSO WE AGREE THAT
WE'RE AT A TIME WHEN PLUG
IN HYBRID ELECTRIC VEHICLES
SOME HAVE STRONGER BATTERIES
AND ARE ABLE TO GO FURTHER ON
ELECTRICITY AND THOSE ARE THE
ONES WE WANT TO INCENTIVIZE
WITH THE SCARCE PUBLIC DOLLARS
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH STRUGGLE WE
HAVE OTHER WITNESSES SPEAKING
IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHURCH ON THE CLAN BEHALF
THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO AND SUPPORT
OKAY --
THANK YOU OF WITNESSES
OPPOSING THE BILL I SEE NO
FURTHER OF SUPPORTERS SO WE
HAVE WITNESSES OPPOSE BILL MUCH
COME FORWARD PLEASE HAVE A SEAT
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
JOHN MOFFITT ON BEHALF OF
THE ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL -- EVEN WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE --
SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE AND
THAT AND ADOPTED BY THE AUTHOR
TODAY YOU KNOW IN IN SHORT
THE GOAL THE STATE HAS A GOAL
OF GETTING THE FIVE MILLIONS
ADS ON THE ROAD BY TWENTY THIRTY
WERE AT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
-- AT THE END OF THE DAY THIS
BILL DOES NOT ACCOMPLISH THE
AUTHOR'S PURPOSE -- YOU KNOW
HAM STRINGING AND CONTINUING TO
PUT CONSTRAINTS ON THIS PROGRAM
WHAT WE RECOGNIZE THERE ARE
BUDGETARY ISSUES IN THAT NEEDS
TO BE BALANCED WE THINK A OR B.
DOES A GOOD JOB OF BALANCING THE
PROGRAM DEMAND WITH THE TYPES
OF VEHICLES A NUMBER OF VEHICLES
THAT -- THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE REBATED VARYING AMOUNTS
WE THINK THAT NEEDS THAT THIRTY
NEEDS TO BE MAINTAINED AT A
A RP AND NOT PUT INTO STATUTE
SO THAT THEY ARE BE DOESN'T HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY THEY NEED TO
ADEQUATELY RUN THIS PROGRAM
IN THE MOST BALANCED AND MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY IN ADDITION
LATER ON IN THIS HEARING THIS
THIS BODY IS GOING TO CONSIDER
ANOTHER BILL THAT IS
GOING TO ASK A ARE BE TO STUDY
WITH THE C. V. R. P. PROGRAM
AND ITS FINANCING AND IT'S
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS SHOULD LOOK
LIKE MOVING FORWARD HOW DOES
THAT WORK WHEN YOU ARE GOING
TO AYE NECESSARILY CONSTRAIN
THE PROGRAM IN STATUTE IN THIS
BILL AND THEN ASK A ARE BE
TO DO A STUDY WITH ONE HAND TIED
BEHIND THEIR BACK ON HOW DO WE
GET TO FIVE MILLION SEVEN BY
TWENTY THIRTY IT MAKES NO SENSE
THE THE APPROPRIATE WAY TO MOVE
FORWARD WE THINK IS TO GO STUDY
THE PROGRAM LOOK AT ADDITIONAL
OPTIONS AND DON'T CONSTRAIN
THE PROGRAM AND STATUTES WE
ARE OPPOSED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
-- WITHHOLD OFFER SECOND WILL
STATUS OF CORN THE AMOUNT
HERE L. PRESENT BASE HERE BATES
PRESENT DALI DALI PRESENT DOT
DODD PRESENT GALGIANI MCGUIRE
MORALE ROSS RUBIO
SKINNER STONE STONE PRESENT
NUMBER RESIDENT CASKEY
CASKEY PRESENT WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN EXCUSE ME I APOLOGIZE
A JULIE MALINOVSKY BALL IN THE
HALF THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION WE ARE
DIRECTLY HAVING A POLICE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITIONS FOR MUCH OF
THE SIMILAR REASONS THAT THE
ALLIANCE HAS OUTLINED IN THIS
COMMITTEE I THINK WE WE ALWAYS
COME BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE ON
BILL SIMILAR TO THIS AND WE TALK
ABOUT IS THIS DOING IS THIS HELP
HELPING US REACH OUR SEVEN GOALS
-- AND IN IN IN THIS PARTICULAR
INSTANCE IT'S NOT AND WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY SYMPATHETIC WITH
WHAT THE PROPONENTS ARE TRYING
TO DO WITH MAKING SURE THAT WE
LIVE WITHIN OUR MEANS OF THE
FUNDS ALLOCATED TO THE PROGRAM
TODAY AND I LIKE IT SAY IS THAT
THAT THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
HAS BEEN HAVING A VERY ROBUST
PUBLIC PROCESS TO DEBATE NOT
JUST INCOME CAPS NOT JUST ALL
LECTER GRANGE BUT DEALING WITH
A DOZEN OTHER TYPES OF CHANGES
YOU CAN MAKE TO THE PROGRAM AND
WE THINK THAT'S THE APPROPRIATE
PLACE TO DO IT WE THINK THAT
THE ANALYSIS IS IS ROBUST
AS WELL AND WE WOULD ASK THAT --
WE WORK ON -- THINGS THAT
HELPED MOVE THE GOALS FOR
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AND
NOT THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU OTHERS SPEAKERS OPPOSING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE A PASS
ON THE BEHALF OF FORD WE ARE
LIKEWISE OPPOSE FOR THE SAME
REASON PREVIOUSLY STATED WE HAVE
A ZEV MANDATE WE HAVE TO REACH
THIS MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT
TO REACH THAT MANDATE THANK YOU
GREG ON OUR BEHALF OF
TOYOTA MOTOR COMPANY
AND OPPOSED TO THE BILL
CHRIS MARABELLA GLOBAL
AUTOMAKERS OPPOSED THE BILL
OKAY --
CAN WE ALSO OFFER VEAS ANY
RESPONSES OR TO WHAT WAS RAISED
NO THIS REQUEST FOR YOU I WILL
MISTER CHAIRMAN I GIVE THANK YOU
ARE QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS -- WE'RE RECOMMENDING
THEM -- APPROVAL WITH
THE AMENDMENTS SIR MOTION
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THIS
NO THE MOTIONS
OKAY I'LL SEE MOTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE DON'T
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL
HE HAD A MEMBER DATE
YOU HAVE THE FLOOR
THAT JUST MAKES
THE FORCE OF THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND SENATOR
SO TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU A.
B. THREE SEVENTEEN A WHICH
WOULD MAKE IT UNLAWFUL OF FOR
PRIVATE COMPANIES TO SELL --
DMV APPOINTMENTS TO THE PUBLIC
APPOINTMENTS ARE FREE TO THE
PUBLIC AND TO REMAIN THAT
WAY IF A COMPANY IS QUICKLY
BOOKING THE ONLINE APPOINTMENTS
INSULIN THEM BACK TO THE
PUBLIC -- IT PUTS LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AT A DISADVANTAGE
I'M HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE THAT
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL SINCE LAST AMENDED A HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
-- CRISIS AS WE SPEAKERS
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
PLEASE COME FORWARD
AND SEE NOT HOW ABOUT
OPPONENTS ANYBODY OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL I SENT A
QUESTIONS FROM OUR COMMITTEE
WE HAVE A MOTION OKAY --
YEAH CLOSE OF RESPECT WE ASK
RIVALS ARE THANK YOU WILL
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SEVENTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE SENATOR
ABOUT ART BELL AYE BATES AYE
BATES AYE DALI DALI I DON
DODD AYE GALGIANI MCGUIRE
MORALES ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STONE STONE I NUMBER
NUMBER I WILL COST ME BECAUSE HE
I LOOKS LIKE YOU
HAVE SEVEN VOTES WHICH MAKES
IT GOOD WE'LL WAIT FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS TO VOTE THE FUTURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR OKAY
AND -- SEE WHAT ELSE WE GOT
HERE WE NEED SOME AUTHORS
WE NEED SOME OFFERS TO SHOW
UP CAN THINK CALENDAR
-- WE GO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE CAN VOTE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS TWO
ITEMS YES YOUR SIXTY
TWO WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER ONE
AND ITEM NUMBER SEVEN A. B.
SEVEN FIFTY TWO AND WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT COUNTER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WELL
WELL I BATES HI BATES AYE
DALI DALI AYE DODD GALGIANI
MCGUIRE MORALE ROTH
RUBIO SKINNER STONE
STONE I AMBER AMBER I WOULD
CASKEY BECAUSE HE ACTS
SIX -- THE
DISCOUNT APPROVED WITH SIX
VOTES AND WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
CONTRAST MEMBERS AND --
WE HAVE MISTER OVER HER --
YOU HAVE TO BILLS SO SOME
WOMEN ITEM TO AB TWENTY
NINE AND ITEM FOURTEEN
A. B. TWELVE TWENTY SIX
-- YOU HAVE THE FLOOR WHICH
ITEM WOULD YOU LIKE TO CONSIDER
TWELVE TWENTY SIX LET'S
GO WITH TWELVE TWENTY SIX
AND THAT'S AND FOURTEEN --
THIS IS -- STATE HIGHWAYS
PROPERTY LEASES AND YOU HAVE
A FOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT TO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE TWENTY SIX CALIFORNIAS
FACING A CRIPPLING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SHORTAGE WITH THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF ON
SHELTERED PEOPLE IN THE NATION
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALONE
RECORD A HOMELESS POPULATION
OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS IN JUNE OF THIS
YEAR AND CITIES WERE SPACE FOR
EMERGENCY SHELTER TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CLOSE TO JOBS SCHOOLS AND PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION IS INCREASINGLY
AT HIGH DEMAND AVAILABLE
SPACE AROUND TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE MUST BE RE
EXAMINED TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF A GROWING HOMELESS POPULATION
IN THE MEDICINE SUPPLY AVAILABLE
SPACE FOR SUPPORTIVE PROGRAMS
SOME MAJOR CITIES HAVE BEGUN TO
USE AIR SPACE UNDER FREEWAYS TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY SHELTER AND
FEEDING PROGRAMS THESE PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED ACROSS
THE STATE AND CITY SUCH AS
STOCKTON SAN JOSE SAN FRANCISCO
SAN DIEGO AND LOS ANGELES
THE -- USE USING SPACE
UNDER FREEWAYS IS HELPFUL IN
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS OF ON
SHELTER POPULATIONS BUILDING
CAPS OVER FREEWAYS CAN ALSO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY SURFACE
AREA TO ACCOMMODATE TRANSITIONAL
SUPPORTIVE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AB TWELVE TWENTY
SIX CODIFIES THE TERM AIR
SPACE AND IS USED BY CALTRANS
WILL ASSESS THE FEASIBILITY OF
BUILDING AFFORDABLE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING OVER BELOW GRADE
HIGHWAYS THE HIGH COST OF LIVING
IN CALIFORNIA MAKES IT NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR SOMEONE THAT
HAS LOST THEIR HOME TO FIND
ATTRACTIVE HOUSING IN THE SAME
NEIGHBORHOOD THIS APPROACH WILL
ALLOW VULNERABLE POPULATIONS TO
STAY ROOTED IN THE COMMUNITIES
THEY CALL HOME I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU A THANK YOU
SOME WOMEN WILL SUPPORTERS
PLEASE I'VE GOT THESE DEFAULT
ABOUT THE ON AT CALTRAIN STATION
COMMISSION WORKER IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL WE THINK THIS NOT
ONLY PROVIDES -- UNIQUE -- USE
OF RESOURCES BUT ALSO COULD
PROVIDE A PRE TO RECONNECTING
NEIGHBORHOODS OF LONG BEEN
SEPARATED BY HIGHWAYS -- BY
CAPPING OVER THEM SO WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
OKAY NEXT SERVICE SPEAKER THANK
OF SPEAKERS IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL OKAY HOW ABOUT OPPONENTS
OKAY -- QUESTIONS
MOVE THE BILL WE HAVE A MOTION
OF JOY TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK HER RIVAL OKAY WE CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CENTER ABOUT HI WELL I BATES
BATES NO DOLLY DODD
GALGIANI MCGUIRE MORALE
MORRELL NO ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER STONE STONE NO NUMBER
NUMBER I WOULD COUNTY BECAUSE HE
AYE THREE
VOTES WILL LIBERAL FOR AFTER
MEMBERS AND WILL GO ON YOUR
NEXT TIME I AM TWENTY NINE OF AB
TWENTY NINE -- ITEM TO DISAPPEAR
IF I COULD I'D LIKE TO TAKE
A TIME OUT ON THAT BILL FOR JUST
MOTOR JUST OKAY WE CAN A MISSILE
GALLAGHER -- COME UP IF YOU LIKE
THANK YOU THANK YOU OF SEVEN ONE
-- MISTER GALLAGHER --
WE WANT YOU TO PRESENT
A. B. FOUR FOUR NINE
AND I APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE IN AROUND THE FLOOR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'LL START BY SAYING HAPPY
ANNIVERSARY AND -- I AM
YEAH I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
AB FOUR FOUR NINE WHICH WOULD
ALLOW YOU THE CITY AS WELL AS
-- THE COUNTIES OF YUBA AND
SUTTER TO KEEP FUNDS FROM
THE SALE OF PROPERTIES THAT
WERE PREVIOUSLY ACQUIRED TO
BUILD A THIRD BRIDGE ACROSS
THE FEATHER RIVER IN THAT REGION
-- INTO A NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
ESTIMATES THAT BRIDGE IT WOULD
HAVE COST APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS -- FORTY FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS THAT -- THAT BRIDGE
PROJECT WAS ULTIMATELY CANCERS
TAKEN OFF OF -- THE LIST
FOR FUNDING AND CAL CALTRANS
IS NO LONGER PURSUING THAT AS A
STATE FUNDED BRIDGE PROJECT
-- HOWEVER AB FOUR FOUR
NINE WOULD ALLOW THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DEVELOP A LOCAL
PLAN -- TO PROVIDE A CROSSING
OF THE FEATHER RIVER THAT
WOULD HELP RELIEVE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION IN THE REGION --
IT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO FILE AN
ALTERNATIVE PROGRAM WITH THE CDC
TO REMEDY -- THE TRANSPORTATION
PROBLEMS IN THE AREA IN
UNDER THIS PROCESS CTC WOULD
MAINTAIN FINALISTS AUTHORITY
OVER THE CONTENT AND APPROVAL
OF THE LOCAL ALTERNATIVE PLAN
IF APPROVED THE LOCAL BRIDGE
PROJECT WOULD COST APPROXIMATELY
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FORTY FIVE MILLION LESS
THAN THE NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
ESTIMATES SO THIS WILL TO RESULT
IN A COST EFFECTIVE PROJECT
IT MEETS LOCAL NEEDS AND WILL
PROVIDE THE THE REVENUES -- HAVE
BY THE SALE OF THESE PROPERTIES
THAT WE ARE GOING TO USE --
-- TO HELP THAT PROJECT -- GO
FORWARD SO AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OKAY
-- I ALSO DO HAVE A WITNESS
IN SUPPORT TODAY IN A LANGLEY
FROM -- THE THE CITY THE CITY
YEAH WELCOME -- YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR HI MY NAME'S
DIANA LATELY AND I IN THE
INTERIM CITY MANAGER FOR THE
CITY OF YUBA CITY WE ARE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS BILL THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF TALK FOR MANY
YEARS ABOUT A THIRD BRIDGE WHEN
CALTRANS DECIDED TO -- DETERMINE
THAT THE RIGHT OF WAY WAS ACCESS
RIGHT OF WAY WE LOOK AT THIS
AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP A
LOCAL BRIDGE AND WORK WITH OUR
REGIONAL PARTNERS TO DEVELOP
THAT BRIDGE I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OKAY
OTHERS SPEAKERS IN FAVOR PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CAROLING ABOUT THE VIEW
BUT COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND STRONG SUPPORT TODAY THEY
WORK VERY WELL WITH THE REGIONAL
COUNTY PARTNERS THAT ON MANY
A STATE PROJECTS IN THE ASKARI
AYE BUT TODAY THANK YOU OKAY
ARE WE HAVE SPEAKERS OPPOSING
THE BILL PLEASE ANYBODY OPPOSING
SEE NO QUESTIONS THE REQUESTED
I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS I
WANTED TO KNOW WHETHER ANY
OTHER EXAMPLES WE'VE TAKEN
OUT CALTRANS MONEY FROM THE SALE
OF PROPERTY AND NOT PUT IN INTO
THE STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT WE PUT
IT INTO LOCAL COMMITTAL LOCAL
JURISDICTION -- WORLD CENTER
CABALLERO HAS A SIMILAR BILLS
THAT I BELIEVE PASSES THIS
COMMITTEE THAT DOES THE SAME
THING WE'VE DONE IT IN PREVIOUS
CASES WITH THOSE TYPES OF
PROJECTS WHERE IT'S YOU KNOW
KEEP THE SALE THAT STATE PROJECT
THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY FOR A STATE
PROJECT ALLOWING THE LOCALS TO
HAVE THAT THAT FUNDING I HAD A
BILL SIMILAR BILL LAST YEAR --
THAT PASSED THIS COMMITTEE AND
IN BOTH HOUSES IT WAS VETOED
BY THE GOVERNOR -- BECAUSE
GOVERNOR BROWN KINDA HAD AN
AVERSION TO TO DO IN THIS
WANTED TO KEEP THE MONEY IN
THE STATE FUNDS SOME MEMBER YOU
HAVE ANOTHER BILL AB FOR THIRTY
WHICH IS PASSED IS GOING THROUGH
THE PROCESS WHICH GIVES A SICK
WICKS EMPTION TO THE CITY OF
YUBA CITY WHICH COINCIDENTALLY
IS FORTY EIGHT MILES FROM
PARADISE BUT GIVES THEM AT AT AT
SEQUEL EXCEPTION FOR FIVE YEARS
OR SIX YEARS SO MY QUESTION
IS CAN MONEY BE USE FROM THIS
PROJECT OR WILL MONEY BE USED
THIS PROJECT TO DEVELOP THESE
HUNDRED THIRTY ACRES THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED IN THIRTY EIGHT
ACRES SERVED IN A FIGHT THAT
WILL BE GIVEN TO THE CITY OF
YOU BY CITY OR THE COUNTY OF
SETTER OR THE COUNTY OF YUBA
A MOTOR WAS COUPLE THINGS IN
THERE ME ONE YES YOU THE CITY
MAYBE FORTY EIGHT MILES AWAY
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF SURVIVORS
FROM THE WILDFIRE LIVING IN
YUBA CITY WE EVEN HAVE A FEMA
-- SITE AT THE YUBA SUTTER
FAIRGROUNDS IN YUBA CITY
-- YOU KNOW FOR CAN'T FIRE
SURVIVORS SO IT IS AN AREA
THAT PEOPLE HAVE COME TO --
YOU KNOW IN IN THE AFTERMATH
OF THAT NO THIS IS THEY'RE NOT
RELATED -- THIS MONEY CAN ONLY
BE USED FOR A LOCAL BRIDGE
PROJECT AT CTC WOULD REMAIN
HAVE BEEN HAVE AUTHORITY OVER
ANY FINAL PROJECT -- AND ALSO
THE LAND THERE IS NOT ZONED
RESIDENTIAL -- SO THEY
WOULDN'T BE ELIGIBLE FOR ANY
DEVELOPMENT UNDER FOUR THIRTY
AS AS FOR THIRTIES PROPOSED
-- OKAY
SIR --
TO TALK ABOUT THE PRINT DEAL
BY PASS DOES THE OTHER ONE
RIGHT CORRECT RIGHT YEAH I
THINK THERE'S BEEN SIMILAR
ONES BEFORE TOO AND THAT'S
BEEN GOING ON FOR WELL SO SO
-- THIS IS LIKE A --
ALLOWING A LOCAL PROJECT
FUNDED WITH STATE FUNDS IS
-- OPTION TO BILLING OF STATE
WILL THIS BE A STATE HIGHWAY
NO IT'LL BE A LOCAL ROAD
OKAY RIGHT BUT -- PROVIDE --
ACCESS OVER THE FEATHER RIVER
RIGHT THAT'S THE WHOLE PURPOSE
OF IT TO DO SOMETHING OKAY
SO THAT'S WHY I HAVE YOU MY
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO SUPPORT
THIS I THOUGHT IT WAS --
A REASONABLE OPTION
-- TO GET A PROJECT GOING
AND -- EYES I WOULD RECOMMEND
SUPPORT FOR THE MEASURE
OKAY HOLD ON A SECOND THE
RECORD WE HAVE A MOTION I
KNOW I KNOW THAT SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IS A SELF HELP PROP
COUNTY WHERE THEY TAX THEIR
CITIZENS TO TO FUND OR PAY
FOR THESE IMPORTANT PROJECTS
IS EITHER YOU BUY OR SELL
EITHER A SELF HELP COUNTY THE
TEXTURE CITIZENS TO BUILD THESE
PROJECTS NO NEITHER ONE IS
AREN'T THANKS YEAH
THE BEST TIME TO ASK VOTERS IN
THAT COUNTY TO TAX THEMSELVES
PROBABLY LITTLE PROBLEM
AND THEY HAVE PROBLEMS ANYTHING
WE DO TO HELP YOU THAT'S MY
ATTITUDE ABOUT IT LET'S GET
THIS YOU KNOW IT'S A GOOD
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT WHISKEY
THIS BILL TO BRIDGE AND ALSO
SAGA MEETS ALL THE STANDARDS AND
SO ANYWAY WE HAVE A MOTION OF
WHO WE -- THIS CALL THE ROLL
THROUGH IN ORDER QUESTIONS LIKE
CLOSER AND CLOSER JUST ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER OUR WILL CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR FORTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CENTER ABOUT BELL AYE BATES
AYE BATES AYE DALI DALI AYE
DODD GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
MCGUIRE MORALE MORRELL AYE ROSS
ROSS I RUBIO RUBIO AYE SKINNER
STONE STONE I AMBER AMBER
I WOULD CASTING BECAUSE YOU KNOW
DODD AYE TEN TO ONE
TEN VOTES -- IMPASSES
LEADER -- PERHAPS MEMBERS
GOOD LUCK THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN CENTERS -- --
MR HOLDER YOU READY TO PRESENT
YOUR REMAINING BILL OKAY
PLEASE COME FORWARD THANK YOU
THIS IS OUR A. B. R. TWENTY
NINE ITEM TWO MEMBERS
SO WE'RE ON ITEM TWO
NEXT ON THE DOCKET IS ZERO
JIM FRAZIER IS AB --
SEVEN OR EIGHT AND THEN --
MISTER BIGELOW THINK THIS YEAR
AREAS OF THE FLOOR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SO I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
THE SENATE BILL TWENTY NINE A
SOLUTION TO A PROBLEM THAT
IS DIVIDED SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
FOR TOO LONG THE BILL REMOVES
THE MOST DISPUTED LAND OF THE
SEVEN SR SEVEN TEN FROM THE
FREEWAY AND EXPRESSWAY CODE
SEVEN TEN NORTH BETWEEN THE
TWO TEN SERVICE TO THE SEVEN
TEN NORTH BETWEEN THE TEN
AND THE TWO TEN OF FREEWAYS
IT ALSO REQUIRES CALTRANS IN
METRO TO WORK WITH THE IMPACT TO
COMMUNITIES AND CAL STATE LOS
ANGELES ON NEXT UPS AND ALLOWS
LAND TO BE RELINQUISHED BACK TO
CITIES FOR TOO LONG THE STATE
HAS BEEN TRYING TO TO DICTATE
WHAT THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES
CAN AND DO WITH THIS AREA LAST
YEAR I US REPRESENTS OF THE
COMMUNITY WHAT THEY WANTED FOR
THIS BILL AND THEY SAID THEY
WANTED THE STATE TO STEP ASIDE
AND LET LOCALS TO SIDE AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO
TRANSISTORIZED BUT THEY CANNOT
IGNORE THE COMMUNITY AND THEY
CANNOT CONSIDER THE NEEDS OF
SOME CITIES BUT NOT OTHERS
THAT IS WHY IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
THE IMPACT TO COMMUNITIES BE
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL PROCESS
LAST YEAR LA MEJOR ON CALTRANS
TO CLEAR THE LOCALLY PREFERRED
ALTERNATIVE TO BE TRAFFIC DEMAND
MANAGEMENT NOT A FREEWAY THIS IS
REFLECTED IN THE FINALIZED THE
I. R. NOW THIS TIME TO COMMIT
TO THE DIFFICULT TASK OF WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY AND CREATIVELY
TO CONSTRUCT SOLUTIONS THAT WORK
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT
OKAY OF SPEAKERS IN FAVOR
OF MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DAVID
JONES OF HALF THE CITIES OF
PASADENA IN SOUTH PASADENA TO
THE MOST IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
-- WITH THE SEVEN TEN WE PLUG
THE AUTHOR FOR -- TAKING THE
STEPS TO TAKE THIS EMBODIMENT
OF WITH THAT REQUIRED GREAT
COMMUNITY IMPACT AND MASSIVE
AMOUNTS THIS IS FIFTY YEARS
THAT THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THIS THIS DECISION
THIS THE FINAL DECISION IS NOT
ONLY TRANSPORTATION DECISION
BUT IT'S BEEN VERY LARGELY A
LAND USE PLANNING DECISION THERE
FOR WHITES WHAT'S OF HOUSING
A WHITE SPOTS OF OPEN LAND AND
SO THE COMMUNITY IMPACT IN THE
OF THE DECISION THAT WITH THE
DISCRETION THAT WE THINK YOU
SHOULD THE DIFFERENCE YOU SHOULD
GIVE TO THE COMMUNITIES OF OF
PASADENA SOUTH PASADENA AND --
HAMBRE WE WOULD HIGHLY RECOMMEND
THAT YOU RESPECT THEIR RIGHTS TO
-- HAVE A LOCALLY CRAFT SOLUTION
SIT DOWN MR HOLDEN DID LISTEN
TO THE COMMUNITIES AFTER MANY
MANY YEARS OF A DEFENSIVE --
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE BILL AND
THE BILL IS CURRENTLY CRAFTED
DOES REPRESENT SPECIFICALLY
THE COMMUNITY IMPACT IN
THE COMMUNITY NEEDS IN THE
COMMUNITY DECISION MAKING --
THAT WENT INTO CRAFTING THIS
BILL GIVEN THE EXTRAORDINARY
-- IMPACT ON THE CITIES OF
PASADENA SOUTH PASADENA AND AND
ALHAMBRA WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THE BILL
IN ITS CURRENT FORM THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SPEAKERS
IN FAVOR PLEASE ABOUT
-- YEAH ARE YOU IN FAVOR
OKAY GO AHEAD CLEAR MEDINA
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE LA
COUNTY ALSO SUPPORT THANK YOU
OKAY HOW ABOUT -- OPPONENTS
ANYBODY OPPOSED TO THE BILL
AND -- OKAY --
-- SLOW HERE FROM --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO SENATOR
SENATOR BUT IT'S OKAY BETTER
I DID IT AGAIN I KNOW
ONE OF MY DOING THAT FOR YOU
KNOW BE A LITTLE ON HONOR
REALIZE THERE'S TWO OF US --
I I DON'T KNOW I WAS THANK YOU
SO MUCH THINK ABOUT YOUR SISTER
AND I WORKING ON -- DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CONGRATULATIONS ON
THE BILL TODAY YEAH YOU'RE
WELCOME SO I'M I HAVE A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS THAT I YOU KNOW
I I DIDN'T GET TIME TRACT
HOUSE DOES THIS BILL CHANGE THE
E. I. R. IN ANYWAY IT DOES
NOT OKAY DOES NOT -- GOING
INTO THIS I HAD MANY CONCERNS
IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE WE SAT
IN A MEETING WITH CALTRANS AND
THEY WERE VERY CLEAR THAT IF
THERE IS ANY CHANGES TO THE ER
THEY WOULD PULL FUNDING FROM
A LOT OF OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
HAVE ALREADY BEEN USING THE
MONEY TO TO MITIGATE SOME OF
THE TRAFFIC AND DOCILE AYE
AYES CAME IN HERE HAVING STRONG
OPPOSITION AS MANY OF YOU FOR
BUT NO AND THAT'S ONLY BECAUSE
A LOT OF MY COMMUNITIES CAME
FORWARD THIS BILL DOES AFFECT
MY DISTRICT MY AREA HOWEVER
I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
TO THE AUTHOR ENSURE SOME OF MY
CONCERNS AND AND I WANT TO SEE
IF THE AUTHOR WOULD BE WILLING
TO REMOVE SECTIONS THREE AND
FOUR FROM THE BILL WHICH SPEAKS
ABOUT THE STUDS EVEN THOUGH
IT DOES IMPACT PASADENA THAT'S
ONE SIDE OF THE STUFF THERE IS
A STEP THAT'S IN MY COMMUNITY
AND I DO AGREE WITH YOU THAT IT
NEEDS TO BE A LOCAL CRAFT A PLAN
AND -- HAMMERS IMPACTED HOWEVER
IF LET'S SAY I'LL HAMMER DECIDES
TO CLOSE THE STUB THAT ALL THE
TRAFFIC WOULD BE RE ROUTED TO
ALL THE OTHER COMMUNITY SOUL IN
MY OPINION IT'S SHOULD BE ALL
THE COMMUNITIES ARE IMPACTED NOT
JUST NUMBER BUT THIS IS MY SIDE
OF TOWN I UNDERSTAND MR HOLDEN
REPRESENTS A PASADENA BUT IF
THE AUTHOR WOULD BE WILLING TO
REMOVE SECTION THREE AND FOUR
THAT DISCUSSES THE STUDS AND
-- AND ONLY FOCUSES ON
THE ACTUAL LANGUAGE FOCUSED ON
THE CALTRANS DECISION FROM LAST
YEAR TOOK DOES CODIFY EVERY MOVE
THE FREEWAY PORTION FROM FROM
THE FREEWAY SYSTEM THEN I WOULD
BE WILLING TO SUPPORT IT BUT
WITHOUT THAT I I CANNOT WOULD
YOU BE WILLING TO DO THAT THAT'S
-- ALSO IN ADDITION TO THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTS REMEMBRANCE
SO YOU WANT TO RESPOND YES
THANK YOU SENATOR MISTER
CHAIR MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE COMMITTEE -- AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS THE SECTIONS THAT ARE
THE SENATOR HAS OUTLINED YEAH
SOMEONE FROM -- FROM
THE FROM THE BILL -- I WOULD
WITH THE RECOGNITION THAT WE
WOULD KIND OF PICK THAT PART
OF IT UP -- AND THEN WORK
TOGETHER ON THIS NEXT YEAR
BECAUSE CERTAINLY COMMUNITIES
THAT WE BOTH REPRESENT ARE STILL
CONCERNED ABOUT PROCESS AND HOW
THEY'LL BE TREATED GOING FORWARD
AND ENSURING THAT THEY ARE
PART OF SOME TYPE OF OFFICIAL
ENGAGEMENT -- I THINK THAT WAS
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO BUT I
WOULD BE WILLING TO TAKE THAT
SECTION THOSE TWO SECTIONS OUT
-- TO ALLOW JUST FOR THIS TO
FOCUS ON -- THE STATE HIGHWAY
CODE ISSUE OF -- REMOVAL
OF THE SEVEN TEN BETWEEN THE TEN
THE TWO TEN WELL I REALLY WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THAT BECAUSE IT
AGAIN HAVE EXPRESSED MY CONCERNS
VERY PUBLIC AND SELL SO REMOVING
THREE AND FOUR REALLY DOES
SATISFY MY CONCERNS -- AND JUST
TO SHARE WITH ANYONE LISTENING
-- BECAUSE -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TOWN I REPRESENT NUMBER IN THAT
DISTRICT HE HAD ALREADY CONVENED
A SUMMIT WHICH WILL HAPPEN NEXT
FRIDAY TO ENGAGE NOT ONLY A
HAMPER BUT EVERY SINGLE CITY
ALONG THE CORRIDOR THAT WOULD
BE IMPACTED AND SO WE'RE I MEAN
THAT NEXT WEEK SO I FELT LIKE WE
WERE GETTING AHEAD OF OURSELVES
AND SELL -- I WILL INCLUDE
ANY OTHER CITIES YOU WANT ME
TO JUST TO HAVE A DIALOGUE
AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE ALL ON
THE SAME PAGE BUT WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS I WOULD BE WILLING
TO SUPPORT IT THANK YOU SO TO
BREAK A CLEARER WERE SECTIONS
ONE AND TWO REMAIN
BUT THE OTHER SECTIONS WOULD BE
DELETED IS THAT ACCEPTABLE
OKAY ANY OTHER THAT IS OUR
YOUTH DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS ON A OKAY ANYBODY
ELSE HAVE ANY COMMENTS
OKAY THEN WE WILL ACCEPT
THE OFFICERS AMENDMENT HAS
CLARIFIED AS THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE VOTING ON IN
THIS COMMITTEE SEC CLEAR
SO WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT
AND ARE THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ANY
OTHER I I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE AND I LOOKED WORKING WITH
SENATOR THANK YOU OKAY --
TWO AM WE HAVE NO COMMENT
I TO WANT TO RECOGNIZE SOME
SORRY NICE TO THE SAID THAT
EARLIER I KNOW MR HOLDEN YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR A VERY
LONG TIME AND AND I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE YOUR COMMUTE IS FOR
FRUSTRATED AS MY COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR
A LONG TIME AND BECAUSE I KNOW
IT'S BEEN AN ISSUE I ALSO VOTED
A FEW MONTHS BACK TO PUT THE
FREE WEIGHT TO REST AND --
SO THIS JUST HELP SOLIDIFY IT
SO IT DOESN'T COME BACK UNTIL
YOU KNOW I DO WANT TO COMMEND
YOU FOR ALL THE WORK YOU'VE
DONE I KNOW IT'S BEEN YEARS
AND I KNOW OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE DONE WITH THE FREEWAY SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
AND I'M HAPPY TO SIT DOWN AND
TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN -- BRING
SUPPORT TRIBES CITY SO THEY FEEL
SUPPORTED AS IT PERTAINS TO THE
DECISION MAKING WITH CALTRANS
THANK YOU OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR A POOL AS AMENDED
OKAY NO MOTION SO WILL
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CENTER ABOUT ON
WELL I BATES BATES AYE DALI
DALI I DON DODD AYE GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MORALE
MORRELL AYE ROSS ROSS I
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SKINNER STONE
NUMBER NUMBER I WOULD CASKEY
NINE OF NINE VOTES IN
FAVOR THANK YOU THE
SALMON -- MISTER FRAZIER
CHAIR FRAZIER IS HERE
AND -- HE HAS --
AB SEVEN AWAY AND
WE'RE GOOD TO SEE YOU
SO THIS IS ITEM SIX SEVEN AWAY
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
FIRST OFF I'D LIKE TO MENTION
THAT WE WILL BE TAKING
COMMITTEES SUGGEST AMENDMENTS
AND I THINK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE WORK ON THIS ISSUE
AB SEVEN OH IT CLOSES A
LOOPHOLE THAT ALLOWS ONLINE
TRAFFIC VIOLATORS SCHOOLS TO
CREATE HUNDREDS OF SIMILAR
NAME SCHOOLS FOR THE PURPOSE
OF DOMINATING THE DMV REFERRAL
LIST THEREBY INCREASING THE
ODDS OF VIOLATORS PARTICIPATING
IN THE STATE TVS PROGRAM
WILL RANDOMLY SELECT ONE OF
THEIR RIGID REGISTERED SCHOOL
NAMES KERN STATUE ALLOWS
MORE THAN ONE LICENSE SCHOOL
TO BE CO LOCATED AT ONE
PHYSICAL LOCATION THIS WAS
WRITTEN ONE BRICK AND MORTAR
SCHOOLS WERE THE PREDOMINANT
MODEL AT THAT TIME ALLOW ME
A SCHOOL ROOM TO BE SHARED
BY MULTIPLE SCHOOL OPERATORS
MADE PRACTICAL SENSE HOWEVER
TODAY THERE ARE FEW BRICK
AND MORTAR ESTABLISHMENTS AND
THE INDUSTRY'S OVERWHELMINGLY
DOMINATED BY ONLINE SCHOOLS
AB SEVEN AWAY WILL REQUIRE
EASE TRAFFIC VIOLATORS SCHOOL
TO HAVE A HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT
PLACE OF BUSINESS THAT IS OPEN
TO THE PUBLIC DURING NORMAL
BUSINESS HOURS AS WELL AS AN
OPERATOR WHO CAN PASS AN AUDIT
IN ORDER TO CRACK DOWN ON THE
PROLIFERATION OF ONLINE ONLINE
TRAFFIC SCHOOLS FURTHER IN
AN EFFORT TO PROVIDE CONSUMER
PROTECTION FROM PROVIDING
PERSONALIZED IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION AB SEVEN AWAIT
WOULD REQUIRE ALL TV SCHOOLS
TO MEET NATIONAL INSTITUTE
OF STANDARDS AND TECHNOLOGY
STANDARDS AND OBTAINING
COMPLIANCE CERTIFICATES CATION
FROM A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
ACCREDITING ACCREDITED ENTITY
TODAY HAVE SCOTT WHAT'S YOUR
TODAY IN SUPPORT AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
THANK YOU ARE ASSEMBLYMAN
ANIMAL HERE FOR SPEAKERS
IN FAVOR PLEASE MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOT WHICH ON BEHALF OF
THE DISTANCE LEARNING COMPANY
CURRENTLY IN NEW YORK
YOU HAVE TWELVE APPROVED
TRAFFIC VIOLATORS SCHOOLS IN
TEXAS YOU HAVE FIFTY IN
CALIFORNIA YOU HAVE OVER TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED EVERY MONTH
YOU HAVE ANOTHER HUNDRED SCHOOLS
BEING REGISTERED WHY BECAUSE
IT NEARLY COSTS ROUGHLY TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO FILE AN
APPLICATION IT TAKES A TEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR BOND WHICH
IS BASICALLY ABOUT FIFTY
BUCKS A MONTH TO CARRY A TEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR BOND FOLKS
PHOTO COPY OR DOWNLOAD BASICALLY
THE DMV HANDBOOK PUT IT ON
A WEBSITE AND THEN WILL JUST
DUPLICATE THE WEBSITE THERE'S
ONE COMPANY IN CALIFORNIA
THAT OPERATES FOURTEEN HUNDRED
ONLINE TRAFFIC SCHOOLS ALL THE
WEBSITES LOOK IDENTICAL THEY
ALL FEET INTO THE SAME PHONE
NUMBER THIS IS BAD BECAUSE
IT HURTS LEGITIMATE OPERATORS
IT'S BAD BECAUSE IT PROVIDES
ZERO TRANSPARENCY TO CONSUMERS
THINK ABOUT THIS WE'VE HEARD
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS FOR FOLKS
HAVE TRIED TO GO TO THE BETTER
BUSINESS BUREAU AND FILE
COMPLAINTS BECAUSE THEY HAD
THEIR CREDIT CARD DOUBLE AND
TRIPLE CHARGED THEY NEVER GOT
THEIR CERTIFICATE THEY FOUND
THAT THE PROGRAM DIDN'T WORK
THEY HAD ISSUES AND PROBLEMS BUT
YET THEY CAN'T FIND EXACTLY
WHO THE OPERATOR IS OR WANTS
THERE'S ENOUGH COMPLAINTS FILED
THAT DOMAIN NAME IS A RACIST
BECAUSE THAT COMPANY HAS ANOTHER
THIRTEEN HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE
IT IS RENDERED THE DMV AUDIT
PROCESS WHERE THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE AUDITING THE SCHOOLS
COMPLETELY -- USELESS
SO THEY CEASE DOING AUDITS
BECAUSE THEY JUST FIND THAT
THEY RANDOMLY WILL JUST KEEP
SELECTING THE SAME COMPANY THEY
DO ONE SCHOOL LITERALLY OPERATES
FOURTEEN HUNDRED DIFFERENT
TRAFFIC SCHOOLS OUT OF ONE
ADDRESS WITH DOZENS AND
DOZENS AND DOZENS OF SERVERS
-- WHICH DOESN'T SERVE THE
PUBLIC INTEREST WHATSOEVER THE
SECOND THING THAT THIS BILL DOES
MISTER CHAIRMAN IS IT PROTECTS
PERSONAL INFORMATION TRAFFIC
SCHOOLS HAVE YOUR DRIVING
RECORD YOUR YOUR DRIVER'S
LICENSE YOUR CREDIT CARD USES
SECURITY NUMBER THEY ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO FOLLOW THE SAME
PERSONAL INFORMATION PROTECTION
STANDARDS THAT CONTRACTORS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DO THIS BILL
WOULD CORRECT THAT SO WE WOULD
ORIGINAL VOTE WE DID HAND OUT
A LIST OF THE CURRENT TRAFFIC
SCHOOLS YOU CAN SEE THAT YOU
HAVE TRAVELED SCHOOLS ARE LIKE
ACNE TRAVEL SCHOOL NUMBER ONE
THROUGH TWO HUNDRED AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PREVENT
BY ONE MORE SPEAKER PLEASE
WHEN MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE GARY ALEXANDER
INTERACTIVE EDUCATION CONCEPTS
WERE LICENSED -- CALIFORNIA
TRAFFIC SCHOOL BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS IN
CALIFORNIA -- I JUST LIKE
TO TESTIFY TO THE FACT OF
HOW IT AFFECTS OUR BUSINESS
AND THE BUSINESS IS THAT I
HAVE FIRST HAND KNOWLEDGE OF
A LOT OF SMALLER COMPANIES WENT
OUT OF BUSINESS IN THE COURSE OF
THE LAST FEW YEARS I KNOW WE HAD
TO SHRINK OUR STAFF OF THIRTY
PEOPLE DEDICATED TO CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS TO ONE PART TIME PERSON
-- THAT FOURTEEN HUNDRED --
SCHOOL OPERATOR THAT YOU JUST
HEARD ABOUT THAT'S A PICTURE
TO THE GLOBAL HEADQUARTERS
TAKEN FRIDAY MORNING NINE
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING
ROUGHLY -- BECAUSE YOU CAN
SEE THIS PLAYED AS A LIKE IT'S
BEEN OPEN FOR WEEKS -- THIS
FOURTEEN HUNDRED SCHOOLS BEING
OPERATED OUT OF THIS FACILITY
-- IS PUTS TREMENDOUS STRESS
ON THE LEGITIMATE OPERATORS
AND A DIRE INDUSTRY EVEN
EXAMPLE WE OPERATE OUR SCHOOLS
IN OTHER STATES WE CURRENTLY
INVESTING HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN OUR CURRICULUM
IMPROVEMENT -- IS THAT GOING
TO BE OFFERED IN NEW YORK AND
OTHER STATES WE HAVE ABSOLUTELY
NO INCENTIVE TO IMPROVE OUR OUR
COURSE AND -- SOME OF THE
COURSES THAT ARE OFFERED
BY THIS VIOLATORS ARE JUST
JUST A BIG JOKE THANK YOU
OTHERS SPEAKERS -- STATE YOUR
POSITION IN YOUR ORGANIZATION
ONLY WHICH CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MANY MISTAKES OLDEST
WITH THE DISTANCE LEARNING
COMPANY AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE
RIGHT RED L. CANS
-- TRAFFIC SAFETY CONSULTANTS
AND I BOTH PLEASE HEATHER
OTHER SUPPORTERS PLEASE
I HAVE A BONUS FOR
THE FURNITURE THE FORD
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PARKER HAVE
BEHALF TRAFFIC ON ONE DOT COM A
WE APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THE BILL WE DO
THINK IT'S AN EXTREMELY -- --
IMPORTANT BILL TO REDUCE THIS
-- GO A LOT OF INTERNET SCHOOLS
-- I WILL SAY THAT IN MY CLIENT
-- HAS OVER A HUNDRED SCHOOLS
ONLY BECAUSE HE DIDN'T WANT
TO GO OUT OF BUSINESS WHEN
THE GUY WAS SWAPPING THEM WITH
FOURTEEN HUNDRED -- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO REDUCING THE NUMBER
SCHOOLS BASED ON THIS BILL WE
SEE THAT THE PLACEMENT IN THE
BILL OF THE -- OPERATOR CLAUSE
AS THE KEY ISSUE THAT WOULD
STOP THIS PROBLEM FROM OCCURRING
-- WE WE DO QUESTION HOWEVER
THE NEED TO GET THE FIFTY FOOT
THE DISTANCE BETWEEN SCHOOLS
THERE MANY PLACES IN -- COMMERCE
WHERE FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU RENT A
CAR FROM HER TO GO TO THE KURDS
COUNTER YOU SEE THE THRIFTY
COUNTER AND THE DOLLAR COUNTER
IN THE SAME PEOPLE AT ALL DOING
THE SAME THINGS IT'S NOT REALLY
THAT CONFUSING FOR THE CONSUMER
-- YOU HAVE RINGING OF OFFICE
SPACE IS A LOT OF TIMES YOU'LL
FIND AN OFFICE SPACE IN THE
BILL REQUIRES A SEPARATE OFFICE
AND WE AGREE WITH THAT -- WE
THINK THAT HAVING TO HAVE FIFTY
FEET BETWEEN IT WOULD LIMIT
OUR OPTIONS ON WHERE WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO LOCATE THE SCHOOLS
ESPECIALLY IF THEY HAVE -- A
SIMILAR OWNERSHIP -- SO FOR
THIS REASON WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO OPPOSE WE DO -- WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR -- CONCERNS THOSE
FOR MANY OF OUR OWN ORIGINAL
-- OPPOSITION POINTS -- THAT
WE'VE HAD SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THE BILL SO WITH THIS
WITH US FOR A NO VOTE PLEASE
-- ANY OTHER OPPONENTS QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE OF THEM OFFER
THE MATH OKAY --
YOU CAN CLOSE OR YOU HAVE
ONE QUESTION CENTER DOLLARS
SO UNDER THIS PROPOSAL HOW
MANY YOU EXPECT WILL BE LEFT
UNDER THE WAY THE BILL IS
WRITTEN PER THE COMMITTEE
MINUTES WE THINK THAT THE
NUMBER OF SCHOOLS FOR SHRINK
DOWN CLOSER TO WHERE TEXAS IS
YOU KNOW AROUND FIFTY OPERATORS
FIFTY OPERATORS OKAY
NOR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
YOU MAY CLOSE THIS RESPECTFULLY
URGE THE COMMITTEE OF
THE I AND I BOTH OKAY
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS SIR MOTION
THE MOTION -- CALL THE CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN OH EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CENTER ABOUT WELL I
BATES DOLLY
DODD DODD I ENJOY JOHNNY
MCGUIRE MERLE BROWN
NO ROTH ROB I RUBIO
SO I SKINNER STONE
STONE NO NUMBER WHAT
CASTING PART
THE BILL HAS
FOUR VOTES IN FAVOR INTO POST
WILL LEAVE THEIR OPEN UP TO
MAKE IT SO MUCH THANK YOU
A SURVEY OF
I WAS GOING TO CALL
COUNTY SUPERVISOR BIGELOW
WHICH IS WHAT I FIRST
MET HIM -- BUT -- CALM
ASSEMBLYMAN BIGELOW YOU HAVE
-- AB SEVEN FIFTY NINE
-- DEALING WITH -- TRAFFIC
SINGLE BARRIERS AND WORK SOUNDS
AND WELCOME AND YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND IS ONCE AGAIN VERY GOOD
TO SEE YOU -- I'LL FRIENDS IN
FACT SEVERAL OF YOUR FORMER
COUNTY SUCH WRITERS WILL WORK
TOGETHER ACCOUNTS INTEREST IN
OUR LIVES ARE INTERTWINED SO
MUCH SO LET ME JUST START OFF
BY SAYING I'D LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE TO US
STAFF IN THE CHAIR FOR WORKING
HARD WITH MY STAFF AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY NINE
EXPANDS THE NUMBER OF SAFETY
DEVICE OPTIONS FOR CONTRACTORS
THAT YOU THAT CAN BE USED AS
A POSITIVE PROTECTION MEASURE
TO HELP PROTECT WORKERS FROM
ON COMING TRAFFIC AS YOU KNOW
MANY TIMES WE HEAR THE STORY OF
SOMEBODY BEING INJURED BECAUSE
SOMEBODY WASN'T PAYING ATTENTION
AND THIS INNOCENT VICTIM -- WAS
JUST DOING THEIR JOB STANDING
THERE IN HIGH WHICH TRYING
TO PROTECT THAT PERSON OUGHT
WELL I'D LIKE TO START OFF BY
ALSO SAYING I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS WHICH WILL BE
HELPFUL TO MAKE THE MEASURE --
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE IN A PARTICULAR
-- MET -- DISTRICT ISSUE
THAT STARTED OUT BUT IT ACTUALLY
IS GOING TO AFFECT ALL OF YOU
-- IN YOUR DISTRICT HI WE WORK
IS IMPORTANT TO KEEP OUR ROADS
IN GOOD CONDITIONS BUT IT CAN BE
VERY DANGEROUS AS A PROFESSION
WORKER SAFETY IS CRITICAL
AS A IS IS A CRITIC CRITICAL
COMPONENT -- TO A. B. SOME FIFTY
NINE AND I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT
TODAY HERE WITH ME IS JOSE MY
HERE -- WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LABOR COUNTS -- LABORS
AND -- HE'S HERE AT TO GET SOME
TESTIMONY AS WELL AS ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY SPEAKERS IN
FAVOR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WAS
IMMEDIATE WITH LABOR STATE
COUNCIL OUR OUR MEMBERSHIP
FOR THE VAST MAJORITY ARE
SEE HOW WE SYSTEM OF THE ONES
THAT BASICALLY SET UP THE LANE
CLOSURES -- BUT JOLLY ANY TYPE
OF ACTIVITY HAPPENING WITH THE
BE OUR STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM
OUR CITIES AND OUR COUNTIES IS
NORMALLY OUR TRAFFIC CONTROL
CONTRACTORS NORMALLY ENGAGE IN
THAT AND THAT COULD BE ANYTHING
FROM HAVING TO DO WITH THE LANE
CLOSURES ANYTHING HAVING TO
DO WITH ANY TYPE OF OPERATION
WHILE ANY TYPE OF ACTIVITIES
GOING ON WITHIN THE WORKS ON I
AM VERY APPRECIATIVE OF OF OF OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MOVING THIS
FORWARD IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
THAT FOR MANY MANY YEARS WE'VE
NEVER HAD THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO USE
MECHANICAL DEVICES IN A POSITION
REQUESTED BY THE EMPLOYERS WHO
ACTUALLY PERFORM THE WORK ON
THESE WORK SITES THERE'S
WE'VE LOST THE NUMBER OF OUR
PEOPLE NOT ONLY FROM THE LABORS
BUT OTHER WORKERS WITHIN THE
WORK SITE THROUGHOUT THE YEARS
MOST RECENTLY LAST SEVENTY NINE
YEARS WE LOST THIRTY TWO LIVES
MANY OF OUR PEOPLE DURING THE
PROCESS OF PICKING UP THE LANE
CLOSURES HAVE BEEN VICTIMS OF
BEING HIT BY A VEHICLES GOING
IN MARIN SHOOTING INTO THE WORKS
ON THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO USE
SOME OF THESE MECHANICAL DEVICES
WHENEVER FEASIBLE WHENEVER
THE THERE'S A THOUGHT OF THE
CONTRACT FROM THE WORK ACTIVITY
IS CRUCIAL TO PROTECTING NOT
ONLY ARE PEOPLE BUT ALSO ANYBODY
IN THE WORKS OWN INCLUDING THOSE
THAT ARE ENGINEERS OR BASICALLY
JUST PEOPLE WITHIN THE WORKS
ON VENDORS ETCETERA ETCETERA
SO IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
AND IS CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
I CERTAINLY RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THE OTHER
QUIRK OTHERS SPEAKERS IN FAVOR
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TIM CRIMMINS
INTERNATION OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS BUT WE ALONG WITH
THIRD ARE BROTHER AND SISTER
THE LABORS PERFORM WORK IN
THESE WORKS AND ALSO -- WE'VE
HAD TROUBLE OUR MEMBERS VICTIM
OF HITS -- WE WERE THE SPONSOR
OF THE MOVE OVER BILL WERE
THE SPONSOR OF THE WORKERS
MEMORIAL YOU SEE EVERY YEAR
FROM THE CAPITAL WERE ALSO
THE SPONSOR OF THE WORKERS
MEMORIAL CAPITOL PARK THAT'S
WHAT A SERIOUS ISSUE THIS IS --
IN IT ALSO THIS BILL ALLOWS A
CONTRACTOR IF HE WANTS TO BID
WORKING UTILIZED NEW SAFETY
TECHNOLOGY TO BE REIMBURSED
-- BY CALTRANS TONIGHT AND NOT
BIT SO AT A DISADVANTAGE IF HE
USES TO USE OF A
MORE STRINGENT SAFETY MESSAGE
TO THE MEASURE SO WE THINK IS
A VERY IMPORTANT BILL OF FOR
THE SAFETY -- MEMBERS BOTH
WORKING FOR PRIVATE CONTRACTORS
BUT ALSO FOR ALL OUR MEMBERS
AND -- STATE BAR YOU TWELVE
WHICH IS YOUR STATE CALTRANS
MAINTENANCE WORKERS WHICH WE
AVERAGE ABOUT FORTY FIVE DEATHS
A YEAR UNFORTUNATELY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THEY SPEAKERS
IN FAVOR PLEASE COME FOR
MY QUEST REPRESENT DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH
YOUR BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TODD
BLOOM SIGN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
THE EMPLOYER SIDE SOME
OF THE EMPLOYERS ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS KIANA VALENTINE ON
BEHALF OF UNITED CONTRACTORS
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU HOW DO WE HAVE
-- OPPONENTS SPEAKERS
OPPOSING THE BILL --
YES SIR COME ON FOR --
I WAS MICHAEL'S FROM COULD YOU
IF YOU WANT YOU CAN COME UP HERE
YEAH GO AHEAD
HAVE A SEAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
APOLOGIZE I ONLY DISCOVERED
THIS ISSUE YESTERDAY AND I
DON'T HAVE A FLOWERY RESPONSE
-- BUT I REPRESENT -- TRAPPING
MANAGEMENT INCORPORATED WERE
ONE OF THE LARGEST PRIVATE
TRACTOR COMPANIES HI IN THE
STATE -- WE SEND OUT HUNDREDS
OF TRAVELERS EVERYDAY INTO THE
-- INTO YOU FEEL PERFORMING
PRIMARILY PRIVATE WORK AND
WE ARE OBVIOUSLY IN FAVOR OF
ANYTHING THE PROVIDE SAFETY TO
BOTH OUR EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS
TO THE PUBLIC HOWEVER WE FEEL
THAT A SPECIFIC TYPE OF DEVICE
THAT IS MANDATED TO BE USED
IN MOST SITUATIONS IS NOT THE
PROPER WAY TO ALLOW FOR SAFETY
TO BE -- UP SHE'D ALL SITUATIONS
OKAY WE TOOK THAT PART OUT WE
MADE AMENDMENTS OKAY I READ
THE BILL AS OF YESTERDAY SO I
READ MISTER BIGELOW IS A CORRECT
CORRECT YEAH SO WE WANT TO TRY
TO TOOK CARE OF THAT NOW YOU
CAN MAKE IT SO IT'S GOING TO
BE CLICK OFF TECHNOLOGY WOULD
USE A FOR YES OR NO -- THAT
WAS IN MY THIRD A SET OF --
COMMENTARY ARE ACCEPTING THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND THE CHAIR HAD PUT FOR TO BE
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL I APOLOGIZE
I DOWNLOADED WHEN I CAN FIND YES
-- HISTORY THAT'S QUITE ALRIGHT
EVERYTHING YOU AND HAVE A FLOOD
THANK YOU FOR WORKING OF CENTER
STONE THANK YOU MISTER CARRIES
ONE OF I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
WE SEE SOME SENSELESS LOSS
OF LIFE -- ESPECIALLY WHILE I
WAS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR AND ON
CALTRANS ROAD SPECIALLY GOING
UP TO THE IDYLLWILD RE A TWO
LANE ROADS YOU HAVE PEOPLE
THAT ARE BICYCLING AT PEOPLE
THAT ARE NOT PAYING ATTENTION
YOU GOT ROAD IMPROVEMENTS THAT
ARE BEING DONE AND PEOPLE ARE
TEXTING AND EMAILING NOT PAYING
ATTENTION THIS THIS ADDED
PROTECTION IS GOING TO SAVE
LIVES AND FUTURE APPRECIATE YOUR
BRING IN FOR MAPPING OF THE BILL
THANK A CLOSER RUBIO
I'M SORRY I I JUST WANNA CLARIFY
-- RATHER FOR IF YOU CAN EXPLAIN
TO ME I KNOW THERE'S A LITTLE
SECTION THAT TALKS ABOUT MEETING
CERTAIN SPECIFICATIONS WHAT JOBS
ARE LIKE WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THOSE THAT REQUIRE
MODEL SAFETY MEASURES VERSUS NOT
IF I MAY MISTER BOB
MOST OF THE SPECIFICATIONS
THAT THAT THEY HAVE TO ADMIT
ARE WITHIN THE D. IT CALTRANS
MENU THAT THEY USE IN
SO BY VIRTUE THIS LEGISLATION
WAS REQUIRING THAT ANY
KIND OF MECHANICAL DEVICES
AND NEW CHOICE WAS SAID EARLIER
BECAUSE AS WE MOVE FOR ALL THIS
NEW TECHNOLOGY OUR RIGHTS TO
BE ABLE TO PROTECT WORKERS ON
THESE PROJECTS IS PROJECT MAKING
REPRESENTS FAR AS I UNDERSTAND
IT I'M WHAT COUNTS AS CORNY
USES SO BASICALLY YOU'RE DOING
THE SAME THING BASED ON ALREADY
ARM SPECIFICATIONS ALREADY IN
PLACE RIGHT WE ARE CENTER IN
IT IN ADDITION I PRICE SHOULD
MENTION THIS ON THAT POINT IS
REALLY APPRECIATE VERY MUCH SO
OBVIOUSLY EVERY INDIVIDUAL OUT
THERE DOING TRAFFIC CONTROL
OR TRAP DELINEATION ANYWAY HAS
TO BE CERTIFIED SB APPROVED
BY AN APPROVED -- PROGRAM
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LABOR'S
BASICALLY WE WE TRAIN AND WE'RE
SELF ACCREDITED ALSO THAT'S
HOW WE PROVIDE THE STE THE
TRAINED PERSONNEL TO BE ABLE
TO MEET THE SPECS SET FORTH BY
THE DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION
THANK YOU I JUST HAPPEN TO HAVE
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT BILL
ANY PROTECTIONS WE CAN OFFER
FOR OUR WORKERS ON THE ROADS I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT NOW
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR SIR
DOLLY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THAT AS SOMEBODY WHO WAS IN THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS WORKED --
ON ROADS AYE THE MOST DANGEROUS
JOBS OUT THERE IS ACTUALLY
TRAFFIC CONTROL AND SO I LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL I THINK THIS
IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY AND HELP
-- OUR WORKERS BE MORE SAFE
THANK YOU AS A BROTHER
OF SOMEBODY WORK SOME PROJECTS
SIDE SUPPORT THE BILL TO
THIS MY SISTER SO
-- WE HAVE NO OTHER QUESTIONS
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU --
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
I'D THIS PARTICULAR BILL IS
-- BEEN NEAR AND DEAR TO ME --
I'M GLAD THE FOLKS OF PRODUCT
FORD AS SPONSORS BECAUSE
I WAS ONE OF THOSE GUYS THAT
ACTUALLY STOOD ON THE HIGHWAY
AND ACTUALLY HAD TO HOLD THE
SIGNS AND AND HAD MANY MANY
DIFFERENT -- NEAR MISSES AS A
CALL FIREFIGHTER I'VE HAD MANY
MANY NEAR MISSES THOSE COULD
HAVE BEEN MUCH MORE TRAGIC HAD
OTHERS NOT BEEN MORE OBSERVANT
AND MAYBE I WAS BECAUSE I
DIDN'T NOTICE THE CARS COMING
AS QUICKLY -- THESE THINGS
HAPPEN YOU DON'T ALWAYS GET
TO SEE EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING
ON AROUND YOU THREE NINE SIXTY
DEGREES AND THAT'S BEEN THE
TRAGIC INCIDENT THAT'S PUT ALL
OF THESE INCIDENTS WERE TRAGEDY
OCCURRED TOGETHER SO I HOPE
-- WITH ALL OF YOUR ASSISTANCE
I CAN LOOK FOR TO AN AYE VOTE
FROM EACH OF YOU THANK YOU NO
THANK YOU I I THINK I THINK THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
ESCALATED TURNS OF LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT TERMS OF SAFETY
AND -- WITH YOUR HELP WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE IT A HIGHER
HIGHER -- LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
PRIORITY THE SAFETY OF OUR --
CALTRANS AND A WORK FORCE
THIS WORKING ON OUR OUR
FACILITIES TO MAKE OUR STATE
-- ALL THE PROJECTS THAT
WE'RE DOING WE'RE DOING A LOT
MORE PROJECTS DOWN WE NEED TO
ESCALATE OUR SAFETY --
OVERSIGHT IN THE LEGISLATURE
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
UP THIS BILL OF KALRA PLEASE
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CENTER ABOUT WELL
I BATES HI BATES AYE DALI
DALI AYE DOT DOT AYE GALGIANI
I MCGUIRE MOREAU HI
MORRELL AYE ROTH ROTH AYE
RUBIO SO I SKINNER STONE
STONE AYE AMBERG WHAT CASKEY
NINE VOTES IN FAVOR OF
LEASE ROLL PRESENT EMBERS
THANK YOU LET'S SEE THE
-- WE HAVE MISTER LACKEY
HERE ASSEMBLYMAN YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR WELCOME TO AND YOU
HAVE A AB EIGHT THREE THREE
AND A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
WHATEVER CEDAR YOU WANT TO STAND
SIX WHATEVER TAKE YOUR PICK
THIS WORKS
AIR WHICH ONE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO START WITH -- IF --
THIRTY THREE OKAY LET'S START
WITH ITEM NINE EIGHT THIRTY
THREE PARKING PENALTY IF YOU
HAVE THE FOUR THANK YOU TODAY
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT IT SB
THIRTY THREE WHICH CLARIFIES
EXISTING LAW REGARDING
ELIGIBILITY THE PARKING
CITATION MONTHLY PAYMENT PLAN
THIS CAN BE VERY VERY SIMPLE
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THE LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED
A PAYMENT PLAN FOR LOW INCOME
DRIVERS WHO RECEIVED PARKING
CITATION THE PAIR PLAN CONSISTED
OF ROLAND FEE NO MORE THAN FIVE
DOLLARS AND MONTHLY INSTALLMENTS
OF NO MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS FOR EIGHTEEN MONTHS THE
CITATIONS THAT THEY RECEIVE MORE
THAN ONE COULD NOT AGGREGATE IN
AMOUNT MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS THE LATE FEES AND
PENALTIES ASSESSMENTS ARE WAIVED
HOWEVER SOME CITIES ARE
CALCULATING THE BASE FEE OF
THE CITATION LATE FEES AND
PENALTY ASSESSMENTS INTO THE
THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR CAP WHICH
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES ACCESS
INTO THE PAYMENT PLAN THE SPIRIT
OF LAW WAS ONLY FOR THE BASE V.
TO BE CALCULATED TO DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY APPARENTLY WE
NEED CLARIFICATION SO THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES AB EIGHT
THIRTY THREE ADDRESSES THIS
ISSUE BY CLARIFYING THE LATE
FEES A PENALTY ASSESSMENTS
ARE NOT ONLY WEIGHED WHAT
SHE AND ROLLED INTO THE
PAYMENT PLAN BUT ALSO ARE NOT
NOT NOT NOT TO BE CALCULATED
INTO THE THREE HUNDRED DOLLAR
CAP TO DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY
BY SELF FRUSTRATED BECAUSE I AM
ANYWAYS TODAY I HAVE WITH ME --
MICHAEL HERALD FOR THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY
WE'LL BE HERE SPEAKERS IN
FAVOR PLEASE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OF MICRO
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY HAS --
YOU KNOW BEEN VERY CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT THE INTENDED PURPOSE OF
THE BILL AS IT REALLY IS SIMPLY
CLARIFICATION OF WHAT WE BELIEVE
WHAT WAS AGREED TO IN AB FIVE A
THREE IN AB TWO FIVE FOUR FOUR
-- AND I THINK THIS HAS HAD
THE IMPACT IN SOME CITIES OF --
MAKING IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR LOAN
COMPLIANCE BILL TO GET ON THE
PAYMENT PLANS WHICH IS WHAT THE
COLD GOAL OF THIS WAS SO PEOPLE
COULD REGISTER THEIR CARS AND
BECOME LEGAL WE WANT EVERYONE
TO BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
LAW -- AND I'M HERE TODAY WITH
A LEGAL SERVICE ATTORNEY --
MISS ROB ANY AS TO TO GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE OF HOW THIS IS
PLAYED OUT IN PRACTICE THANK YOU
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ROBERT BEATTY AS I'M A VOLUNTEER
ATTORNEY WITH BAY AREA LEGAL AID
IN THE RICHMOND OFFICE FOR
THE LAST SIX MONTHS I'VE BEEN
REPRESENT A CLIENT WHO NEEDED
HELP LIFTING A DMV HOLES ON HIS
CAR REGISTRATION THAT HOLD WAS
TO IN PART TO TO SEVERAL UNPAID
PARKING TICKETS MY CLIENT IS A
SEVENTY NINE YEAR OLD DISABLED
VETERAN WHO HAD A STRING OF
BAD LUCK AND WOUND UP IN A
HOMELESS SHELTER WELL LIVING
AT THE HOMELESS SHELTER HE A
HAVE TO PARK HIS TRUCK ABOUT
A MILE AWAY AND EVERY MORNING
YOU HAVE TO GET UP EARLY AND
WALK TO MOVE THE CAR BEFORE
THE NO PARKING RESTRICTIONS
WENT INTO EFFECT DESPITE HIS
BEST EFFORTS HE WOUND UP WITH
FOUR TICKETS TOTALING A HUNDRED
SIXTY DOLLARS AND YOU JUST
COULD NOT PAY THEM OVER TIME
WITH THE PENALTIES IN LATE
FEES THAT AMOUNT OF A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY DOLLARS BALLOON TO
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY DOLLARS
MY CLIENT IS INDIGENT WHOSE
SOLE SOURCE OF INCOME IS A
SOCIAL SECURITY CHECK SO I HOPE
TOMORROW FILE AN APPLICATION
WITH THE CITY FOR A AN INDIGENT
PAYMENT PLAN UNDER THAT PLAN
YOU'D BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN DOLLARS
TO BE SPREAD OVER EIGHTEEN
MONTHS ABOUT TWELVE DOLLARS
A MONTH WHICH MY CLIENT SAID
HE THOUGHT HE COULD HANDLE UP
ALL THE LATE FEES AND PENALTIES
WOULD WOULD BE WAIVED AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO LIFT THEIR HOLD
WOULD BE LIFTED ON HIS DIEM
AT DMV HE BE ABLE TO REGISTER
HIS CAR I WAS VERY SURPRISED
WHEN AND WHAT CAME BACK FROM
THE CITY WAS A REJECTION OF
THIS APPLICATION AND WHEN I
INQUIRED WHAT I WAS TOLD WAS
THAT HIS TOTAL WAS TOO HIGH
OVER THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
I RESPONDED THAT HIS TOTAL
WAS ACTUALLY WELL BELOW THREE
HUNDRED -- BUT THEN I WAS
INFORMED BY THE CITY ATTORNEY
THAT THEIR INTERPRETATION
WAS THAT THE STATUTE SAYS
THIRD YOU INCLUDE ALL THE
PENALTIES SO IT'S FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY IN FACT THE CITY'S
DECIDED TO TREAT THAT THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AS A DATING
MECHANISM IN ORDER TO DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE PROGRAM
NOT AS THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT THAT
CAN BE FINANCED UNDER IT A
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
INTENT OF SECTION FOUR OO TO TWO
OO WAS IN FACT THAT THE TOTAL
AMOUNTS TO SHOULD BE THE AMOUNT
OF THE BASE FINES NOT THE
SO WITHOUT ACCESS TO THIS
PAYMENT CRIME MY CLIENT WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO MAKE PAYMENTS
AND WILL NOT BE ABLE TO REGISTER
HIS CAR AND ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU FOR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
TO HELP HIM AND OTHER PEOPLE IN
HIS RICHARDSON FAVOR THE BILL
PLEASE FOR LEADERS IN FAVOR
I INCOME ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
HELLO HELLO GOING TO ADDRESS
ON BEHALF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
-- ABOUT OPPONENTS
THE OPPONENTS THANK
YOU A QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE MOTION
OF THE SEVEN ONE YOU CAN
CLOSE I WOULD JUST ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THE
SERVER FIND BILL THANK YOU
OKAY THAT'S THE THIRD LACKEY
BILL ON THE SUBJECT IT IS
IF IT WORK ON OUR HEARTS SO
THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT THIS
IS SECOND CAN I ASK I KNOW
IT'S A LITTLE TOO LATE DO YOU
MIND IF I GO AHEAD I JUST WANT
TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO YOUR
CLIENT WERE YOU ABLE TO TO HELP
THEM GET IT IS CIRCUMSTANCE NO
THE CITY IS STILL INSISTING THAT
HE CAN'T PARTICIPATE IN THE PLAN
OKAY FIGURES TO I'M FRUSTRATED
I JUST THINK THIS IS A CENTER --
THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT I THINK
HE WROTE TO STATUTES AND THEN
I THINK SOMEBODY INTERPRETED
YOUR STATUTES IN AND CONTRARY
TO WHAT THE -- DISPATCHES
INTENDED NOW YOU HAVE TO
AS WE DO A LOT OF TIME SOMETIMES
GO BACK AND CLARIFY IT FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE MISINTERPRETING
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES
SO THANK YOU RICHARD --
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT SO --
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE ON THIS
THIS IS THE SENATE BILL EIGHT
THIRTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LACKEY -- SO WITH WOMEN
YEAH GO AHEAD YEAH SO BUT
WILL HOLD ALL OVER THE WORLD
THIS BILL DOESN'T HAVE AN
URGENCY ON IT RIGHT NOW
DOES IT TODAY HAVE A TWO
THIRDS VOTE IN THE ASSEMBLY
NO IT DID NOT THEY
DID NOT OKAY THANK
YOU AUTHORS TRISH
THAT'S A GOOD THOUGHT
THOUGH ROLL THE DICE
AND WHEN YOU DO THAT SO
OKAY THANK YOU OKAY CALL
MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CENTER ABOUT HI
WELL I BATES HI BATES AYE DALI
DALI I DON DON AYE GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MOREAU
MORRELL AYE ROSS ROSS I
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SKINNER
STONE STONE AYE AMBERG CASKEY
WE HAVE NINE VOTES CENTROLEGAL
PRESS MEMBERS THANK YOU FOLKS
THANK YOU -- AS A NUMBER
OF A SECOND BILL LAUGHING
WILL HAVE -- THE SECOND BILL
IS THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE AND --
WILL TURN IT OVER YOU
FOR THE OF THE FLOOR SAY
BE THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
ITEM FIFTEEN --
THIS DEVELOPMENT
LAST
THE OTHER FOUR OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
VOTE OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES
TO CONSULT WITH THE PUBLIC
TRANSIT OPERATORS TO ASSESS
THE PROCEDURES ADMINISTRATION
OF RIGHT SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH PHYSICAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
TAKE NEARLY A MONTH BEFORE
PERSON WITH A DISABILITY CAN
USE AND AGENCIES PARA TRANSIT
SERVICE MOREOVER IT'S EVEN MORE
BURDENSOME FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES WHO NEED A RIDE
IN A JURISDICTION OUTSIDE THEIR
ORIGINALLY APPROVED SERVICE AREA
FOR EXAMPLE IF AN INDIVIDUAL
WAS DEEMED ELIGIBLE FOR SERVICE
IN SACRAMENTO BUT WAS VISITING
LOS ANGELES THAT INDIVIDUAL
WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
LENGTHY PROCESS TO PROVE THEIR
ELIGIBILITY WHICH INVOLVES
LISTEN TO THIS FAX MACHINE
OKAY THIS BILL INITIATES THE
PROCESS IN WHICH OUR STATE CAN
BEGIN TO IDENTIFY GAPS AND DIAL
A RIDE A PER TRANSIT SYSTEMS
AND BEGIN STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS IN WHICH INDIVIDUALS
WITH PHYSICAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES CAN USE THE RIGHT
SERVICES FREEWAY ME TO TESTIFIED
SUPPORT OUR REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AND ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA STATE
EMPLOYEES WITH DISABILITIES
BECAUSE A FAVOR PLEASE WELCOME
BOBBI DATA I'M REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA STATE EMPLOYEES
WITH DISABILITY ACCESS
AND WE'RE IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL
FOR A NUMBER OF REASONS I'M
A STATE EMPLOYEE AND IF I'M
GOING TO BE USING A PARATRANSIT
SERVICE TO VISIT A CLIENT HAD
ANOTHER AREA LET'S SAY I WANT
TO GO TO ROADS FEEL BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE THE REHAB CENTER
IS FOR DEPARTMENT OF REHAB
UP I'M GONNA HAVE TO CALL THEM
UP MAKE ARRANGEMENTS AND THAT
TAKES TIME THEY WILL VERIFY
BY THE TIME TO GET DOWN TELLING
ME THAT I COULD HAVE A RIDE MY
APPOINTMENTS OF ALREADY PASSED
SO THAT'S ONE EXAMPLE ANOTHER
EXAMPLE WOULD HAVE BEEN JUST
SIMPLY IF I WANTED TO TAKE
GO FOR A JOB INTERVIEW FOR
ONE STATE AGENCY TO ANOTHER
SAME THING WOULD OCCUR NOT TO
MENTION THE MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS
AND NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS
AGAIN I'M SUBJECTED TO THIS
TYPE OF DELAY WHICH ULTIMATELY
DENIES THE ABILITY TO ACCESS
TRANSPORTATION SO CONSEQUENTLY
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT TAKES AWAY ALL THE
RESTRICTIONS THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST THANK YOU THANK YOU
OTHERS SPEAKERS PLEASE GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATE SENATORS
MY NAME IS ERIC HARRIS I'M
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA A
NONPROFIT ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
THAT ADVANCES IN PROTECTS THE
RIGHTS OF CALIFORNIANS WITH
DISABILITIES WE SUPPORT A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE A BILL THAT
WOULD REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY TO CONDUCT
AN ASSESSMENT OF THE PROCEDURES
PUBLIC TRANSIT OPERATORS
USE OPERATORS USE TO PROVIDE
A DIAL A RIDE IN PARA TRANSIT
SERVICE TO INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES WHO ARE VISITING
THE SERVICE TERRITORY THEIR
SERVICE TERRITORY DEAR SEE
SUPPORTS INCREASING ACCESS TO
TRANSPORTATION INCLUDING RIDE
SHARING AND PARA TRANSIT AS
MOBILITY OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES CONTINUE TO
INCREASE WITH THE ADVENT OF
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES AND WHO RIDE
SHARING SERVICES TRAVEL OUTSIDE
OF ONE'S HOME SERVICE TERRITORY
MAY ALSO RISE THIS BILL REQUIRES
THE AGENCY TO TO LOOK AT THIS
ISSUE STATEWIDE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE CURRENT POLICIES
FOR VISITORS AND DETERMINE
IF A STATEWIDE SOLUTION IS
NEEDED WE BELIEVE THAT A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE WILL IMPROVE
TRANSPORTATION ACCESSIBILITY
FOR PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND WE URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU -- OTHERS SPEAKERS IN
FAVOR PLEASE COME FORWARD
THREE THE ANDERSON ON BEHALF
OF THE ARE CAN YOU SEE P.
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION
AND SUPPORT THANK
CITY JACKSON ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES PARKER AN ARCADE IS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL S.
TRANSPORTATION ACCESS IS A MAJOR
AND REOCCURRING ISSUE FOR PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
LACK OF ACCESS TO CONSISTENT
RELIABLE TRANSPORTATION IS A
FUNCTIONAL BARRIER TO EMPLOYMENT
TO COMMITTEE INTEGRATION AND
THE ABILITY TO THE ONCE LIKE
WITH THE SAME LEVEL OF ACCESS
TO PEOPLE WITHOUT DISABILITIES
TAKE FOR GRANTED THANK YOU OKAY
-- OTHERS SPEAKERS IN FAVOR
PLEASE ABOUT -- OPPONENTS
WE HAVE THE BONUS COME FOR
THIS IS ABC
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
WE HAVE A MOTION THE BILL FROM
THE OPPONENTS YES SIR WELCOME
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL HERE
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION -- REGRETFULLY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I
KNOW THE BILL DOES ATTEMPT TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS AND THE
VISITOR STATUS FOR EIGHTY IMPAIR
TRANSIT ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS --
WITH THE GOAL OF ESTABLISHING
ESTABLISHING AS YOU HEARD --
WHAT'S REFERRED TO IN THE BILL
AS STATEWIDE RECIPROCITY --
NOW THE STATEWIDE RECIPROCITY
IS ALREADY A LARGELY THE LAW
OF THE LAND AND WELL SPOKEN
TO IN STATE AND FEDERAL LAW
-- THE LETTERS WE SUBMITTED TO
THE COMMITTEE SPOKE TO THAT --
TRANSIT AGENCIES IN SHORT MUST
HONOR -- PROOF OF EIGHTY EIGHT
PARA TRANSIT LEGEND BILLY AS
PRESENTED NOW WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE CAN BE FRAGMENTATION THAT
SYSTEM -- THAT SET TIMES THE
PROCESSING CAN BE SLOW -- BUT
WHAT I WOULD NOTE IS HERE LIKE
IN MANY THINGS RELATED TO PUBLIC
TRANSIT THAT'S OFTEN A RESULT
OF -- DIFFERENCES IN RESOURCES
BETWEEN AGENCIES DIFFERENCES
IN STAFFING -- AS WELL AS
ON THE DIFFERENCES IN USING IN
HOUSE OR OR CONTRACTS STAFFS
-- IN SO FROM OUR ASSOCIATIONS
PERSPECTIVE -- CURRENT LAW
ALREADY SPEAKS TO THIS AND TO
THE EXTENT OF THE STATE WERE
TO TO REVISIT THIS IT OFTEN
WOULDN'T THEY WOULD LIKELY FIND
ON THE SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
REALLY EXIST WITH THE RESOURCES
THAT TRANSIT AGENCIES HAVE NOT
NOT ANYTHING THEY'RE DOING OUT
OF THE LITTLE RISK RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOU KNOW THE
ANYBODY ELSE THAT WANTS TO
SPEAK AND AGAINST THE BILL
I SEE NONE ABOUT OF QUESTIONS
FROM OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CENTER STONE AND THE SEARCH FOR
FOR THE OPPONENT I MEAN WHY NOT
JUST RE DEDICATE RESOURCES WERE
TALKING UP PEOPLE THAT -- ARE
SEVERELY DISABLED THAT NEED TO
GET FROM POINT A TO POINT B. AND
SOMETIMES ON HAVE TIME FOR A
-- A NEED TO SEE TO TO APPROVE
SUCH TRANSFERS -- MEMBER
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT YOU'RE
NOT COMING FORWARD IN TRYING
TO COME UP WITH A SOLUTION AND
INSTEAD OF COMING UP HERE AND
AN OPPOSING GOOD BILL LIKE THIS
FOR NOW AND THAT'S THAT'S A
VERY FAIR QUESTION I THINK THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO PUBLIC TRANSIT
-- THE SERVICE JUST ALMOST
INHERENTLY IS ONE THAT IS UNDER
RESOURCE ACROSS THE BOARD WHEN
IT COMES TO PARA TRANSIT -- AND
EDA A SERVICE THAT TENDS TO
BE THE MOST EXPENSIVE SERVICE
THAT WE ACTUALLY DO PROVIDE
HIGH TIMES IT CAN BE FORTY TO
FIFTY DOLLARS PER RIDE -- AND
SO AGENCIES DOING AS MUCH AS I
CAN WITH THE RESOURCES THAT THEY
UNFORTUNATELY ARE ARE ARE GIVEN
-- OFTEN MEANS THAT WE HAVE TO
-- RENEGE ON WHAT WHAT MIGHT BE
RESPONSIBILITIES -- -- THAT THAT
THE STATE OR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MADE ME SEE -- SEE FIT TO APPLY
THE ONE THING THAT WOULD NOTE
IS -- ONE THING THAT WE DID
OFFER AND I THINK YOU COULD
MAKE SOME SOME GOOD SENSE -- IS
JUST REQUIREMENTS THAT THERE'S
SOME MODERNIZATION WITHIN THE
PROCESS SEES THAT AGENCIES
-- TAKE ON AND AND -- THE AUTHOR
NOTED THAT FOR SOME AGENCIES IS
STILL RELY ON FAX MACHINES WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S AN OLD
FANGLED TECHNOLOGY IT'S GOING
TO BE INHERENTLY SLOW SO ONE
OF THINGS THAT WE HAD PRESENTED
EARLY ON IN THIS PROCESS --
WITH SHOULDN'T TO KIND OF A TWO
PART SOLUTION ONE WOULD BE TO
REQUIRE THAT TRANSIT AGENCIES
-- PRESENT ON THE WEBSITE
AND THROUGH THE TELEPHONE ON
THE EXACT TIME LINES AT THE
REQUIRE FOR PROCESSING --
THESE -- THESE -- CERTIFICATIONS
BUT THEN ALSO -- REQUIRING
THAT THE EXCEPT THE PROOF OF
ELIGIBILITY -- VIA ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATION SO WHETHER THAT'S
EMAIL OR UPLOADING ON A WEBSITE
-- THOSE WITH THINGS WITH
OFFERED -- WINTERS AND THAT
THE AUTHOR -- HAS A DIFFERENT
-- -- VIEWPOINT FOR HOW THIS
BILL SHOULD PROCEED I OWN THEM
ON FORTUNE WHICH SAID IN THE
PAST THERE YOUR COMMENTS AND
I THINK BY A PASSING THIS BILL
I THINK OF AGENCIES ARE GONNA
HAVE TO ADOPT PROGRAMS THAT ARE
MORE HOMOGENEOUS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE -- GIVE A HIGHER PRIORITY TO
THOSE THOSE -- DISABLED PEOPLE
TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE TRANSPORTATION NEEDS
MET GOING TO THE DOCTOR GOING
TO GROCERY STORE ETCETERA SO
-- I'M DELIGHTED WITH THE BILL
AND HOPE THAT -- YOU WILL WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND -- AND
MAKE IT TO A SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM
MORE SIX OF THEM AND WE HOPE IT
WILL BE A THANK YOU OTHER
COMMENTS FROM MEASURES PORTIONS
OF THE JUST JUST TO RESPOND
-- I THINK SETTING POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES ARE ONE
THING AND THEN ACTUALLY
DOING IT IS ANOTHER I THINK
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THAT I
HEAR FROM MY CONSTITUENTS
-- IN THESE KINDS OF --
-- TRANSISTORS SCISSORS
IT'S ALWAYS POLICIES
BUT THEY JUST DON'T
WORK DATE THERE ARE NOT
THE THING DOESN'T IT
DOESN'T WORK RIVER THAT AS
WHAT THE POLICIES SAY --
THE PARA TRANSIT PROGRAMS
ARE IN ESSENCE A REQUIREMENT
-- OF OF CIVIL RIGHTS
MEASURE CALLED AMERICANS
FOR DISABILITIES ACT IT
SAYS IS IT'S A CIVIL RIGHTS
ISSUE AND THEREFORE SHOULD
BE TREATED AS --
AN ITEM THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY
-- A BURDEN ON THE TRANSIT
DISTRICT IN TERMS OF COST
BUT AND MANDATORY ELEMENT
OF THEIR SERVICE TO PROVIDE
ACCESS FOR TRANSPORTATION FOR
ALL PEOPLE IN THE IN THE
COMMUNITY SO IT'S SO SO ACTUALLY
SHOULD BE VIEWED AS MORE OF
A A RITE OF SOMEBODY TO HAVE
THE ACCESS TO TRANSPORTATION
OF AND I THINK ESPECIALLY FOR
PEOPLE THAT NEED ASSISTANCE
IN THEIR TRANSPORTATION
NEEDS WHETHER THEY'RE
DEVELOPING DISABLED OR
PERSONS WITH OTHER --
ISSUES THAT NEED TO HAVE
ASSISTANCE AND I THINK
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE SO
RIGHTS LAW SO SO MY VIEW
IS THIS IS A GOOD BILL THEY
SHOULD REGULARLY REVIEW THESE
PROCEDURES AND REGULARLY LOOK AT
WHETHER OR NOT AGENCIES THE
RECEIVING STATE FUNDS THERE
WE ARE GIVING THEM FOR OPERATING
ASSISTANCE ARE ACTUALLY USING
THE FUNDS FOR A PEOPLE
THAT HAVE -- A NEED
FOR A SISTER TRANSPORTATION
SO WE'RE GIVING THEM MONEY
WE'RE WE'RE WE PUT EXTRA
MONEY IN SP ONE WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO HELP WITH THE OPERATING
ASSISTANCE AND I'M SURE THE
TRANSIT AGENCIES WANT TO DO
THIS BUT I THINK THEY SHOULD
B. EXAMINING THE PROCEDURES
WITH THE DISABILITY
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE DOING IT
IN A PROPER WAY SO
SO THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
I THINK -- THE BILL ACCOMPLISHES
I DON'T THINK IT'S A -- I
THINK WHEN PEOPLE LOOK AT THE
BILL THEY SAY WELL THEY'RE GONNA
LOOK AT THE PROCEDURES WELL
THE PROCEDURES ARE THE ISSUE
THEY ARE THE ISSUE HOW YOU
ACTUALLY CONDUCT YOURSELF IS
THE ISSUE SO THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL I URGE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL UP THE STORE QUESTIONS
WE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
THIS IS THE LEVEL THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LACKEY THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SENATOR ABOUT
I BATES HI BATES AYE DOLLY
DOLLY I DON DON AYE GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MORALE
MORRELL AYE ROSS ROSS I RUBIO
THE -- AYE SKINNER STONE
STONE I AMBER WHAT CASSIE
NINE VOTES WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
THANK YOU GENERAL WORK ON THE
SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON
YOU'RE HERE AND WELCOME
IN THIS IS THE TENTH ITEM ON THE
AGENDA AND IT'S A. B. TEN TWENTY
FIVE IS --
THE SAN RAMON BRANCH
QUARTER PROJECT OKAY WELCOME
WHEN YOU ARE THE FOR AARON
MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND THEIR TIME AND ATTENTION
ON THIS BILL AB TEN TWENTY
FIVE REMOVES THE OBLIGATION FOR
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY TO REIMBURSE
THE STATE OF TRANCE STATE FOR
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT ACCOUNT GRANTS USED
TO DEVELOP THE SAN RAMON BRANCH
CORRIDOR THIS IS HOME TO THE
IRON HORSE REGIONAL TRAIL IT
WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE COUNTY TO
INCLUDE A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE C. C. T. A. ON THE IRON
HORSE TRAIL QUARTER MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM ADVISORY COMMITTEE
THIS BILL RECOGNIZES CONTRA
COSTA IS -- CONTINUED INVESTMENT
IN THE MULTI MODAL PATHWAYS
ALONG THE SAN RAMON BRANCH
CORRIDOR AND IT ALSO ALLOWS
THE COUNTY TO CONTINUE PLANNING
TO MAXIMIZE THE IRON HORSE
REGIONAL TRAILS BENEFITS FOR
CONSTITUENTS IN THE BAY AREA AND
WOOD CHAIRS PERMISSION I WILL
HAVE MY WITNESS SELF INTRODUCE
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MARC WATTS REPRESENTING THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE TO COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO MR
GRAYSON FOR INTRODUCING THIS
MEASURE FORCE MOVING ALONG
A SICKLY WILL ALLOW THE COUNTY
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE QUALITY
MULTI USE TRAIL SERVICES IN THE
CORRIDOR BUT AT THE SAME TIME BE
PREPARED IF THERE ARE EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES WE HAVE WILL HAVE A
SYSTEM IN PLACE WITH THROUGH OUR
COMMITTEE TO REVIEW AND ANALYZE
THEM AND TAKEN THROUGH THE
CHEN TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
SO WITH THAT WE WOULD ASK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU OTHERS SPEAKERS
AND WE HAVE OTHER SPEAKERS IN
FAVOR PLEASE HOW ABOUT
OPPONENTS HAVE ANY BONUS
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION
QUESTION THEY OFFER
OKAY AND YOU HAVE A CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE SENATE
THEY WILL CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
THIS ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TWENTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CENTER ABOUT
WELL I BATES DALI
DALI AYE DODD DODD AYE GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE TOMORROW
MORRELL NO ROSS ROSS
I RUBIO NO I SKINNER
STONE STONE NO AMBER
WHAT CASKEY I WAS GIVEN
THE FACT THAT THE SIX OF SIX
WAS A FAVOR WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
AND -- SEE WE USE OF AUTHORS
SO TAKE A LITTLE
BREAK HERE THE ONE
FOR THE OFFER STRONG
ONE GOOD
YEAH
RIGHT
--
THE BILL
THE CASHIER
ASSEMBLYMAN WE HAVE
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
KAMLAGER-DOVE AND SHE HAS
ITEM TWELVE AB ELEVEN HUNDRED
THANK YOU GET THEM GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I AM PRESENTING AB
ELEVEN HUNDRED WHICH WILL ALIGN
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING CODE
WITH LOOKING LOCAL PARKING
ORDINANCES TO SUPPORT ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
NGUYEN IN EVEY CHARGING STATION
IS INSTALLED IN A PARKING
SPACE THE BUILDING CODE DEFINES
EXPLICITLY THAT IT'S A CHARGING
SPOT AND NO LONGER A PARKING
SPOT THE BUILDING CODE ALSO
REQUIRES THAT ONE OF THE FIRST
FOUR CHARGERS INSTALLED IN
A LOT BE INSTALLED IN A VAN
ACCESSIBLE SIZE SPACE WHICH
PHYSICALLY REQUIRES COMBINING TO
NORMAL SIZE SPOTS TO MAKE PLEASE
REQUIREMENTS RESULT IN MANY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS REQUIRING EVEY
CHARGING COMPANIES TO CONSTRUCT
ADDITIONAL PARKING SPACES TO
OFFSET THE QUOTE UNQUOTE LOST
PARKING SPACE TO MEET LOCAL
PARKING REQUIREMENTS BUILDING
AN ADDITIONAL PARKING SPACE
IS OFTEN COSTLY TECHNICALLY
UNFEASIBLE CAUSING CHARGING
PROJECTS TO BE DROPPED ENTIRELY
OFTENTIMES SUCH TECHNICAL ISSUES
CREATE ARBITRARY BARRIERS TO
STATION DEPLOYMENT WHICH IS
INCONSISTENT WITH OUR LONG
TERM CLIMATE GOALS NOW
SOME MUNICIPALITIES INCLUDING
CINEMA AND SACRAMENTO COUNTIES
AND THE CITIES OF STOCKTON
AND LOS ANGELES TO NAME A FEW
HAVE RECOGNIZED THESE ISSUES
AND HAVE PASSED ORDINANCES TO
FIX SOME OF THEM HOWEVER MOST
OTHER MUNICIPALITIES HAVE NOT
TAKEN SUCH MEASURES WE NEED
TO HELP COMMUNITIES ACCESS
THIS IMPORTANT TECHNOLOGY TO
INCREASE CONSUMER CONFIDENCE
IN ELECTRIC VEHICLES AB ELEVEN
HUNDRED HELPS ACHIEVE THIS BY
CLARIFYING THAT PARKING STALLS
WITH PHOEBE CHARGING STATIONS
CAN STILL COUNT TOWARDS PARKING
REQUIREMENTS AND WOULD ALSO
ALLOW THE AND ACCESSIBLE EVEY
SPACES TO COUNT AS TWO PARKING
SPACES FOR PURPOSES OF COMPLYING
WITH PARKING REQUIREMENTS
TODAY WITH ME AND SUPPORT IS
COREY BILL AS WITH THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU SEVEN ONE AND WE'LL
HEAR FROM THE SPEAKERS IN
FAVOR GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS CORBELS
ON BEHALF OF THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ASSOCIATION
-- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF KIDS
COMPRISED OF COMPANIES THAT
DESIGN INSTALL AND MANUFACTURE
EVEY CHARGING EQUIPMENT AND
SERVICES MANY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
HEADQUARTERED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
-- THE STATE AS A GOAL TO PULL
TO DEPLOY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND CHARGING STATIONS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE KNOTS TO
SUPPORT ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
E. VIS WE ALSO HAVE A GOAL TO
DEPLOY FIVE MILLION E. VIS BY
TWENTY THIRTY SO THAT NUMBER
IS GOING TO NEED TO INCREASE
SIGNIFICANTLY IF WE'RE GOING
TO MEET THE FIVE MILLION EVEY
DEPLOYMENT TARGET THE ISSUES
THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAYS
OUT CAUSE US TO LOSE SCORES
OF VIABLE CHARGING INSTALLATION
PROJECTS A YEAR ACROSS THE
ENTIRE STATE -- AND REALLY DOES
CREATE AN ARTIFICIAL BARRIER
FOR US AT LEAST TO GET MORE OF
THESE THINGS IN IN THE FIELD
IN SUPPORT OF OUR CHARGING
DEPLOYMENT GOALS AND IT'S REALLY
NOT YOU KNOW AN ISSUE THAT IS
UNIQUE TO ONE CITY OR COUNTY
MEANWHILE -- AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER POINTED OUT MANY
MUNICIPALITIES HAVE PASSED THEIR
OWN LOCAL ORDINANCES THEY'RE
IN THE MINORITY COMPARED TO THE
REST OF THE STATE SO IT REALLY
DOES BAG FOR STATEWIDE POLICY TO
SOLVE SOME OF THESE -- TECHNICAL
INS INCONGRUENCE HE'S -- AROUND
-- THESE INSTALLATION ISSUES
I MEAN REALLY THE END RESULT
IS MANY PLACES THAT WOULD BE
A PRIME SPOT FOR INSTALLING A
CHARGING STATION WE LOSE OUT ON
AND THAT'S TO THE DETRIMENT OF
OUR DEPLOYMENT GOALS AND A. B.
ELEVEN HUNDRED WILL HELP TRIP
THOSE INCONSISTENCIES THANK YOU
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL PLEASE YES JULIE
NINE ASK ABOUT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION IS A
SMALL BUT MIGHTY BILL ADVANCING
THE -- INSTALLATIONS A. B.
B. CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE
ASK YOU FOR SUPPORT THANK
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ROD BREWER FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY KELLY TO
SEE IN THE THE -- CALIFORNIA
WE'RE HERE SUPPORT AS WELL
TWENTY GARCIA WITH CAL STAR
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AARON RODRIGUEZ OF THE UNION
OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT MICHAEL
THE AFTER THE PRAYER AND
MCHALE LEA ON BEHALF OF
CHARGE POINT IN SUPPORT
DÂN JOHN BEHALF TESLIN SUPPORT
EMILY OLSEN OF ADVANCED
ENERGY ECONOMY IN SUPPORT OKAY
-- WILL SPEAKERS OPPOSING THE
BILL PLEASE ANYBODY THE
BILL WE HAVE NO POINTS OF A
MOTION AND -- THE QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE NOT
IF YOU HAVE A CLOSE I HAVE
SOME A PHASE SAY THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THAT
I THINK AB ELEVEN HUNDRED AS
PRAGMATIC AND REASONABLE AND
HELPFUL TO LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES
AND WE WE CAN'T BE HELPFUL
IF WE CAN'T BE HELPFUL SO
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HELPFUL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
OKAY -- CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
THE BILL ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS CENTER ABOUT ALL
RIGHT WELL I BATES NO BATES
KNOWN DOLLY DODD GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MOREAU ROTH
ROTH AYE RUBIO SKINNER STONE
STONE AYE NUMBER FOUR CASKEY
THEREFORE VOTES IN FAVOR
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE PERHAPS
OF NUMBERS AND WE'LL GO TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FILL CHIANG
HE'S GOT TWO BILLS IN
THE FIRST IS ITEM ELEVEN
AB TEN FORTY SIX
THE SECOND AS I AM SIXTEEN AB
SIXTEEN OH FIVE AND YOU HAVE A
PREFERENCE ON WHICH ONE YOU WANT
TO START WITH JUST GOING FOLLOW
ORDERS BY ORDER OKAY LET'S GO TO
AB TEN FORTY SIX THANK THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR WORK OUR CONVERSATIONS
IN FOR THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS
ASSISTANCE ON THIS BILL WE'RE
HAPPY TO TAKE THE AMENDMENT
AS OFFERED BY THE COMMITTEE
AGAIN WE'VE HAD A VERY
SUCCESSFUL CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROGRAM TO DATE GOTTEN US TO
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND CLEAN
CARS ON THE ROAD IN CALIFORNIA
HOWEVER AS YOU JUST HEARD FROM
THE PREVIOUS AUTHOR IN THE
PREVIOUS WITNESS WE ARE WELL
SHORT OF OUR ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION VEHICLE GOAL BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE IN OUR FIVE MILLION
VEHICLE GOAL BY TWENTY THIRTY
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO WORK FOR TO
PARK WORK WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO REALLY REINVENTION
AND HAVE A MUCH LONGER TERM
PLAN ON BUT THE CLEAN VEHICLE
REBATE PROGRAM SHOULD LOOK
LIKE I THINK YOU SHOULD LOOK
MUCH MORE LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR INITIATIVE WHICH STARTED
HIGHER AND THEN WENT TO ZERO
HAVE A SET AMOUNT OF TIME SO
THAT THE HOPE WOULD BE WE CAN
ACHIEVE WHAT WE DID WAS SOLAR
WHICH WAS SOLAR TODAY IS NOW
AS COST EFFECTIVE AS OTHER
FOSSIL FUEL ENERGY SOURCES
THE GOAL WOULD BE IF WE WERE
ABLE TO CREATE A LARGE MARKET
FOR CLEAN CARS THAT THEY BE
COST COMPETITIVE WITH GAS CARS
SO WITHOUT WE THINK THIS THIS
BILL IS A VERY KEY COMPONENT
THAT PROGRAM IS A VERY KEY
COMPONENT ON MOVING OUR WAY INTO
TO OUR FIVE MILLION CLEAN CAR
FUTURE BY TWENTY THREE WITHOUT
WOULD TURN OVER TO MY WITNESS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
GERALD WITH THIS -- THE OTHER
FOUR GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS EMILY OLSEN I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF ADVANCED
ENERGY ECONOMY AND NATIONAL
MULTI TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
OF BUSINESSES WORKING TOWARDS
A CLEANER SAFER AND MORE
AFFORDABLE ENERGY SYSTEM WE'RE
HERE TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FORTY SIX
WHICH PROVIDES A TIMELY PRUDENT
APPROACH TO IMPROVING THE
CVR PART P. PROGRAM SO IT
ACTUALLY MOVES MARKETS THE WAY
CALIFORNIA NEEDS IT TOO IN ORDER
TO ACHIEVE OUR STATE'S PULLED
TRANSPORTATION GOALS WE NEED
TO ATTRACT BUYERS AT ALL INCOME
LEVELS AND GEOGRAPHIES THE
C. B. R. P. PROGRAM CURRENTLY
DOES NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
HANDLE THE PRESENT AND GROWING
DEMAND FOR CLEAN VEHICLES THE
PROGRAM IS ALSO NOT CURRENTLY
EQUIPPED TO PROVIDE SUFFICIENT
INCENTIVES TO BRING NEW TYPES
OF BUYERS INTO THE FOLD MORE
CALIFORNIAN FOR MEANS COULD BE
ENJOYING THE BENEFITS OF C. B.
R. P. BUT THEY ARE CURRENTLY
UNABLE TO UNDER THE EXISTING
STATUS QUO FAR FROM SET UP FOR
SUCCESS THE C. B. R. P. PROGRAM
HINGES ON PRECARIOUS STOP AND
START FUNDING AB TEN FORTY SIX
WOULD REFOCUS ATTENTION ON THE
BEST WAY TO FUND THE C. B. R.
P. SO THAT THE PROGRAM DELIVERS
MARKET TRANSFORMATION AND
RESTORES MUCH NEEDED CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE BY DIRECTING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE TO LOOK INTO
OTHER OPTIONS FOR LEVERAGING
EXISTING FUNDING SOURCES THIS
BILL CAN GET OUR STATE BACK ON
TRACK AND PUT OUR STATE DOLLARS
TO BEST USE THIS WILL IN TURN
ENSURE THAT WE GET THE MOST
VALUE FROM OUR TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS IN OTHER WORDS THIS
BILL PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TAKE A GOOD HARD LOOK AT
THE KIND OF INNOVATIVE REBATE
PROGRAM WE NEED TO GET THE
JOB DONE AND MOVE THE NEEDLE
ON OUR TWENTY THIRTY GOALS IN
CLOSING AB TEN FORTY SIX SIX
TO SOLVE SEVERAL CHALLENGES
THE PRACTICAL MARKET DRIVEN
APPROACH THAT WILL MAKE CV ARE
PETE MORE EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE
AND ROBUST A. W. SUPPORTS THIS
BILL AS A LOGICAL AND NECESSARY
NEXT STEP FOR CLEANING UP
OUR TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IN
SECURING OUR ZERO EMISSIONS
FUTURE AND WITH THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR IPHONE
AB TEN FORTY SIX THANK YOU
OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR PLEASE
PEOPLE ARE IN FAVOR OF THE BILL
THANK YOU ARE BRINGING US HERE
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
TELL DROUGHT NUMBER HAVE
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
IN JAVA TESLIN SUPPORT
OKAY OKAY OF
OPPONENTS PLEASE
COME FORWARD WELCOME
TELL CAN COME UP HERE AND SEE
SELECT THE EMPTY SEATS
WELCOME MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE JOHN MOFFITT ON BEHALF
OF THE ALLIANCE OF AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS WE WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL IMPRINT -- WHEN THE
BILL WAS LAST HEARD -- WE RAISE
TWO ISSUES ONE RELATED TO FEE
BATES THE OTHER RELATED TO
MORE SPECIFICITY ON THE FUNDING
SOURCES IDENTIFIED THE BILL FOR
SECURITIZATION WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S WORK IN THE AND
THE AMENDMENTS OFFERED TODAY
THINK THEY GO A LONG WAY --
TO TO DEALING WITH THE CONCERNS
THAT WE HAD ORIGINALLY RAISED
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IS AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD TO GO
A LITTLE MORE MEAT ON THE BONE
WITH RESPECT TO THE FUNDS THAT
COULD BE SECURITIZED WE BELIEVE
THE CVR P. PROGRAM IS VERY
IMPORTANT IN A KEY COMPONENT TO
GETTING TO THE STATE'S ZEV GOALS
-- YOU KNOW WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT WHEN
THAT THE C. B. R. P. PROGRAM
STARTED ITS PURPOSE WAS TO
PROVIDE AN INCENTIVE TO GET
THE AVERAGE CAR BUYER TO LOOK
AT ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE AND
CHOOSE THAT OVER ITS INTERNAL
COMBUSTION ENGINE COUNTERPART
OVER TIME THE ONE OF THE
GOALS OF THE PROGRAM IS ALSO
BEEN EQUITY HOW DO WE HELP FOLKS
OF LOWER AND MODERATE INCOMES
ALSO GET INTO THESE VEHICLES
WE THINK BOTH HER OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS LEAH SO WITH OUR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE AND THE
WORK OF THE AUTHOR IN CLARIFYING
SOME ISSUES WE INITIALLY RAISED
SOME CONCERNS AND STILL HAVE
A LITTLE BIT OF CONCERNS WITH
RESPECT TO MAKING SURE THAT THE
BILL IS TECH NEUTRAL -- ALTHOUGH
WE DO THINK THE AMENDMENTS ARE A
LONG WAY TOWARDS -- TOWARDS
UP IN THE BILL SO WE DID HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ALSO WITH THE
LACK OF LEGISLATIVE CONTROL OVER
AIR BEES USE OF FUNDS AND WE
HOPE THAT THE WE LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING THE AMENDMENT SAYS
PRESENTED -- WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL AND PRINT SO WE DO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
TO A POINT WHERE WE CAN REMOVE
OPPOSITION OKAY THANK YOU
-- OTHERS SPEAKERS JOHN WHEN
YOU'RE ON THE HAVE A CALIFORNIA
FEELS INCONVENIENCE ALIGNS WITH
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE CHAMBER
DO YOU THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS THANKS
I'M JUST SIGH YOUNG ABOUT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS
VEHICLES COALITION I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF THE CHAMBER I'M IN ARE
WAITING TO SEE THESE AMENDMENTS
AND PRINT ALSO ON BEHALF OF
CLEAN ENERGY I WAS ASKED TO
RELAY THOSE SAME COMMENTS AND
ALONG WITH THAT ON BEHALF OF
THE BIO ENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED SPECIFICALLY FOR TWO
REASONS NUMBER ONE WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL SHOULD BE AMENDED
TO BE TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL ARE
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
SHOULD BE AMENDED TO IT DRESSED
LIFECYCLE EMISSIONS THANK YOU
AFTERNOON I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MARGOT PARKS
AND THE HAVE THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION -- SAME
CONCERNS AS ECHO LOOKING FORWARD
TO SEE THE BILL AND PRINT I DO
THINK THAT THE SECURITIZATION
ISSUE STILL NEEDS -- A LOT
MORE WORK TO SEE WHAT THAT
ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE WHAT FUNDS
ARE GOING TO BE USED I THINK
THAT'S STILL SERIOUS OUTSTANDING
ISSUE -- AND THE BILL LOOK
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK ON THIS THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS RECORD ASKINS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED BIO
FEELS ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION
WIENER -- ERIN ORTEGA'S TO THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
ARE WE APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
THIS ON THE NUMBER AND THE STAFF
HAVE DONE ON THIS BILL I'M A
REALLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE INTENT
OF THE BILL BUT WE'D LIKE TO
SEE SOME LANGUAGE AROUND EQUITY
ON HAND AND HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
ON THE FUNDING OF IT -- WE LOOK
FOR THE WORKING WITH BOTH OF YOU
OKAY -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PERHAPS -- IF YOU WANT TO GO
OVER THE JUST THE RESPONSE
TO ENTER THE AMENDMENTS BECAUSE
I THINK IT PERHAPS CLEARER
FOR IS A LOT OF THE OPPOSITION
-- THAT WE ARRANGED IN THE
AMENDMENTS OF ONE IT SHOULD
GO THROUGH THOSE OF YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE MINUTES FIRST
THING THERE WAS THE CONCERN
THAT THE BILL WOULD ALLOW OR
DID NOT DISCUSS THIS ISSUE
AROUND I ACTUALLY CHARGING
CHARGING FEES ON GAS CARS TO
PAY FOR THE CLEAN CARS THE CODE
OF PHOEBE THE CALL FEEDBACK
OF OUR FREE BIT I DON'T KNOW
SIR BECAUSE I JUST WANT AS MUCH
FOR HIS FATE IN ENGLISH RATHER
THAN A TERMINOLOGY WE DON'T
WANT TO START YEAH TERMINOLOGY
THE CAR WE TOOK A MOMENT
ABSOLUTE CLARIFIED THAT THAT
WAS NOT THE INTENTION OR THE
YOU KNOW AND IT FUNDING STREAM
-- YEAH I I AS YOU KNOW AS
ASSEMBLY BUDGET CHAIR I I HAVE
ARE REALLY STRONG FEELINGS ABOUT
HOW MONEY GETS SPENT AND WHERE
KIDS IN THIS MONEY THIS BILL
DOESN'T APPROPRIATE ANY MONEY
-- IT DOES ALLOW A. R. P. TO
TAKE A LONGER LOOK AT THIS
PROGRAM AND TO SEE WHAT WE
COULD DO TO MAKE IT BETTER THE
HOPE IS THAT WE CAN OBVIOUSLY
FLUSH THAT OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE
FOR FOR ME IT'S ALSO OKAY LET A
RB FLUSH IT OUT AS WELL SO
-- THAT IS THE THAT'S THE HOPE
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO MEET
AND TO FIND A FUNDING SOURCE
BUT AGAIN -- IF IT TAKES LONGER
I THINK IT'S TOTALLY FINE FOR
A RB TO DO THAT TO IDENTIFY THE
SOURCE NOW OBVIOUSLY IN ORDER
TO UTILIZE ANY FUNDS TO UTILIZE
THE FUNDING MY EXPECTATIONS
THEY WOULD HAVE TO COME BACK
TO LEGISLATURE TO GET APPROVAL
FOR THAT -- SO THAT'S TOTALLY
-- INCLUDED THE LEGISLATURE
WILL OVERSIGHT OF ANY PLAN
THAT COMES OUT OF THIS SO
I THINK THAT GIVES US SO
THE BALL COMES BACK ON OUR
CORD AFTER THEY COME UP WITH A
PLAN SEXUALLY AND AGAIN --
WE WE DON'T PICK ANY
SITES IN THIS TECHNOLOGY
WHAT WE DO IS AGAIN THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROGRAM
HAS A CERTAIN SET STANDARDS
ON WHAT KINDS OF VEHICLES
FOUND AND SO WE HAVE NOT
SPOKEN ON THAT PARTICULAR SHOW
OKAY OKAY
THANK YOU -- DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THERE'S A MOTION
QUESTION SIR GALGIANI
ORIGINALLY I WASN'T GOING TO
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL BECAUSE
I AS I UNDERSTOOD IT THEY
WOULD HAVE BEEN IFFY ON THOSE
WHO WERE DRIVING GAS DRIVEN
VEHICLES WHICH MANY ARE IN MY
AREA AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
BECAUSE THEY QUITE FRANKLY CAN'T
AFFORD ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
DON'T HAVE THE CREDIT RATINGS
WITH THE CREDIT ABILITY TO
BUY AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE AND
SHOULDN'T BE PENALIZED BECAUSE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY TRYING TO
COMMUTE TO THE JOBS RICH AREAS
-- IN YOUR DISTRICT BUT NOW THAT
YOU'VE CHANGED THE BILL I WILL
BE SUPPORTING IT BUT IT'S WITH
THE CAVEAT THAT YOU HAVE MADE
THAT CHANGE SHOULD HAVE MADE IT
CLEAR THAT THAT MY CONSTITUENTS
CONSTITUENTS WON'T BE PAYING THE
PENALTY ABSOLUTELY NOT THAT'S
WE WANT TO TAKE THAT LANGUAGE TO
CLARIFY WE UNDERSTAND THERE ARE
SOME ISSUES AROUND HOW TO
INVOLVED WORKING CLASS FAMILIES
-- MORE LOWER INCOME FAMILIES
IN THIS PROGRAM WHAT I WOULD
SAY THAT THAT IS THERE THERE
IS A -- A CASH FOR CLUNKERS
PROGRAM WE'VE ALSO CONSIDERED
-- SHOULD BE BROUGHT IN THIS
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE USED VEHICLES
I THINK THE CHALLENGE FOR
MANY WORKING FAMILIES THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS DON'T NECESSARILY BUY
USED CAR BUY NEW CARS THEY BUY
USED CARS YES SO THIS IS A NEW
CAR PROGRAM IS OBVIOUSLY I THINK
THERE'S DEFINITELY INTERESTED
OPENNESS ON MY END TO CONTINUE
THAT DIALOGUE TO FIGURE OUT HOW
CAN WE BETTER SERVE A USED CAR
MARKET BECAUSE THE GREAT THING
ABOUT NOW THAT WE HAVE CARS
THAT HAVE BEEN ON BEEN OUT FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS YOU NOW HAVE
A USED CAR MARKET THREE FOUR
YEARS AGO FIVE YEARS AGO YOU
DIDN'T HAVE THE USED CAR MARKET
BECAUSE ALL THE TECHNOLOGY
WAS NEW SO I THINK IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FIGURE OUT AGAIN
HOW TO -- PROVIDE A BROADER
INCOME SPECTRUM SO I THINK WE'RE
STILL WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT
THIS THERE IS A AGAIN A CASH
FOR CLUNKERS PROGRAM MY HE AT
E. S. M. T. MFA I WAS FORGET
THAT HOW THE ACRONYM WORKS --
IT'S BETTER JUST TO CALL IT LIKE
A CASH FOR CLUNKERS PROGRAMS OF
DOUBT PROGRAMS IS STILL THERE
WE DON'T WE DON'T TOUCH THAT
BUT I THINK -- WE DEFINITELY
WANTED TO CLARIFY THE WHOLE
FEE ISSUE THAT WAS UPSET NOT
THE INTENTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU OF OTHER
MANY QUESTIONS OKAY THE MOTION
SENATE ROTH DO YOU HAVE A CLOSE
THANKS FOR ALL THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION WE CONTINUE AGAIN
TO WANT TO WORK WITH ALL THE
OPPOSITION WE THINK MANY OF
THE CONCERT THAT RAISED WORRY
WE FULLY ANTICIPATE BEING ABLE
TO WORK SO TO SUM IT UP WERE
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND BUT MADE
BY VOTERS WHAT WAS THE NUMBER
IS FIVE HUNDRED LOOKING PROBLEM
LITTLE CLOSER TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WERE ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND WE HAVE TO GET TO
WE WANT TO GET TO ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
WE WANT TO GET TO FIVE MILLION
BY TWENTY THIRD OKAY THAT'S WITH
THE GOVERNOR IS GOING TO HAVE
TO WORK WITH US ON THIS TO GET
BASICALLY TO THOSE GOALS BECAUSE
WE HAVE REALLY TANGIBLE GOALS WE
HAVE TO GET TO THOSE GOALS WE'RE
WE'RE GONNA WORK ON GOVERNOR
KNEW SOMEONE THAT AND MAY OUR
RIGHT YOU KNOW GOVERNOR BROWN
DOESN'T HAVE THAT MUCH TO DO SO
MAYBE YOU CAN HELP US AS WELL
HE COULD BY A COURT OKAY
WE HAVE A MOTION THANK YOU AND
THE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE THIS IS
A SILLY ABOUT TEN FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CENTER ABOUT WELL I BATES
ALI DAWALY NO DODD GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MORALE
ROSS ROTH AYE RUBIO SKINNER
STONE STONE NO AMBERG CASKEY
THREE VOTES IN FAVOR WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE FROM ABSENT MEMBERS
OF A SEVEN THANK YOU AND
WE'LL GO ON TO YOUR NEXT ITEM
IS -- AB SIXTEEN OH FIVE SO AB
SIXTEEN OH FIVE SO LONG MARCH ST
-- IT IS -- I DISTRICT BILL --
I GOT A HOUSE BY OR COUNTY FOR
OUR COUNTY BOARD IN OUR COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY KERRY
THIS BILL -- LUMBAR STREET IS
PROBABLY OUR MOST FAMOUS STREET
IN SAN FRANCISCO WHICH ARE
CROOKED STREET ALL ON A GIVEN
WEEKEND IN THE SUMMER YOU COULD
DRAW UP TO SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE I REPEAT SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT'S ONE
HELLUVA WILL BLOCK PARTY SO
FOR ALL THE RESIDENTS NOT JUST
ON THAT BLOCK BUT IN THAT AREA
IT BECOMES A CHALLENGE TO LEAVE
THEIR HOME GO TO THE GROCERY
STORE COME BACK IT CAUSES
A HUGE AMOUNT OF TRAFFIC
CONGESTION WERE YOU HAVE A LINE
THREE OR FOUR BLOCKS DOWN THE
ROAD SO WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING
IS TO GIVE THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO AUTHORITY TO
SET UP A RESERVATION SYSTEM
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE'VE DONE
FOR MERE WORDS IN MARIN TOO
SO THAT TOURIST WOULD PAY
FOR A RESERVATION WE THINK
IT'S A WIN WIN SO THE TOURIST
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT IN LINE FOR
HOURS THEY WERE SET SET AMOUNT
OF TIME THAT THEY CAN COM IT
ALSO HELPS RELIEVE CONGESTION
AND IT ALSO INSURERS THAT
IT'S A MUCH SAFER ENVIRONMENT
BECAUSE WHAT THE RESERVATION
WOULD PAY FOR IS WHO PAY FOR
TECHNOLOGY IN TERMS OF UP THERE
WOULD NOT BE GATE BUT THERE BE
TECHNOLOGY TO SCAN THE LICENSES
THIRD ALSO WOULD BE PEOPLE THERE
TO MANAGE THE SIDEWALKS EVEN
WHEN I WAS THERE ON A TUESDAY
MORNING TO DO A PRESS CONFERENCE
THE COUPLE HUNDRED PEOPLE ON
THE STREET -- IN AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE AS PEOPLE COME DOWN THE
CRICKET STREET WHAT ARE PEOPLE
DOING PEOPLE ARE STANDING IN THE
MIDDLE THE INTERSECTION TAKE A
PHOTO BECAUSE THAT'S THE BEST
PLACE TO TAKE A PHOTO FOR THAT
ST NOT YOU CAN IMAGINE FROM
A TRANSPORTATION TWENTY THREE
YEAH STANDING IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE INTERSECTION AS HUNDREDS
OF CARS ARE COMING DOWN THE
STREET IS NOT A VERY SAFE PLACE
TO STAND SO OF COURSE WE WE
WANNA MAKE SURE TOWARDS HAVE A
GREAT EXPERIENCE WE WANT MAKE
SURE THEY DON'T GET HIT BY
CARS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
CARS AREN'T HITTING PEOPLE THAT
ALSO WERE MANAGING PEDESTRIANS
BUT THAT'S GOOD THAT REQUIRES
RESOURCES AND SO WE'RE ASKING
FOR FORTY FROM THE STATE TO
CHINA TO SET UP A RESERVATION
SYSTEM FOR THAT ONE BLOCK IN
THE CITY COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO
OKAY WAS BECAUSE THEY WERE
THE BILL THANK YOU CHAIR
IN THE HUDDLE WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY I JUST WANT TO
MENTION THAT THE SYSTEM THAT
MR TANG -- DISCUSSED JUST NOW
I WAS THE RESULT OF I THINK
THREE YEARS AND COUNTING OF
COMMUNITY BASED STUDY -- AS THAT
ARRIVED AT THIS RECOMMENDATION
-- THE COMMUNITY IS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SYSTEM AS WELL
AS THE LOCAL REPRESENTATIVE
DISTRICT TO REPRESENTATIVE
CATHERINE STEPHANIE AND THE
BOARD OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS -- AS THE AS THE
SHOOTING MENTION WE REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS BEING
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED AS
A WIN WIN FOR BOTH -- THOSE
OF US IN CHARGE OF MANAGING
TRAFFIC IN THE AREA -- AND FOR
VISITORS TO WANNA COME ENJOY
SAN FRANCISCO THANK YOU OTHERS
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR OKAY
JUST IN TIME CAPTION THIRTEEN
CAROLING OTHER OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS FOR THE CITY
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO IT'S PART
THANK YOU COURSE OKAY
-- DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ANY OPPONENTS BY OPPOSE
THIS BILL WILL BE A MOTION
OF I HAVE A TRUE PURSUIT
QUESTION HOW MANY MOVIES AT
LOMBARD STREET AND IT IS THAT SO
IS IT I I DON'T KNOW I'M ASHAMED
TO SAY -- THERE'S QUITE A FEW
-- -- NUMBER ONE WITH
-- CLINT EASTWOOD
STEVE MCQUEEN OR IT WAS DOES
THAT MOVIE SO WE HAVE
TO GET THAT ANSWER FROM SOMEBODY
YES THAT'LL BE A GLOBAL DRUMMER
PURSUIT QUESTION GET THAT READY
FOR THE SENATE FLOOR OKAY GET
THE RATE FOR THE SENATE FLOOR
-- OKAY LET'S CALL THE ROLL AND
MOTIONS FOR APPROVAL THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING
MOTION IS TO PASS CENTER
ABOUT I FELL AYE BATES NO
BATES NO DOLLY DONE GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MOREAU
ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO SKINNER
STONE STONE NO -- BURKE CASKEY
THREE VOTES IN FAVOR WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
AND WE'RE GOING DOWN THE LIST
HERE AND WE HAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL WELCOME
AND THIS IS ITEM THIRTEEN
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE
YOUR BEFORE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE WHICH
DIRECTS THE A A RP TO CONSIDER
ALLOWING OIL AND GAS COMPANIES
TO CLAIM AN INNOVATIVE
PRODUCTION METHOD CREDIT FOR
USING RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
DELIVERED BY A COMMON CARRIER
PIPELINE RIGHT AT THE SOURCE
REDUCES METHANE EMISSIONS
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HELLO CARBON IT HELLO CARBON
FUEL STANDARD OR ELSE CFS IS
PRIMARILY PRIMARILY DESIGNED
TO ENCOURAGE THE USE OF CLEAN
LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
FUELS IN CALIFORNIA
THE PROGRAM IS ALSO INTENDED
TO REDUCE EMISSIONS DURING THE
ACTUAL PROCESS OF PRODUCING
TRANSPORTATION FUELS AS SUCH
THE PROGRAM ALLOWS OIL REFINING
OPERATIONS TO GENERATE EL
CFS CREDITS WHEN SWITCHING
FROM TRADITIONAL NATURAL
GAS TO RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
HOWEVER THIS PROGRAM DOES NOT
INCLUDE OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION
DESPITE THE LARGE AMOUNT
OF NATURAL GAS REQUIRED BY
ENHANCED OIL RECOVERY METHODS
INCLUSION OF THESE PRODUCERS
COULD HELP REDUCE EMISSIONS
AND CREATE A HEALTHY MARKET
FOR RENEWAL THAT NATURAL GAS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE DIRECT
THEIR AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO CONSIDER EXPANDING LCF
OF CREDITS TO OIL AND GAS
PRODUCERS WHO REDUCE METHANE
EMISSIONS HERE IN CALIFORNIA BY
SWITCHING TO RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS IN THEIR OPERATIONS AND
HERE'S TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
ARE THE IS THE -- CALIFORNIA'S
STATE -- PIPE TRADES AND I
BELIEVE OTHERS MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU -- SPEAKERS IN FAVOR
YEAH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
-- PAYLESS REPRESENT IN THE --
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL -- WE VERY MUCH SUPPORT
THIS BILL THIS IS ALL ABOUT
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION IN THE
PRODUCTION OF OF GAS AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE OF EXTRACTION OF OIL
AND GAS AS YOU CAN IMAGINE WE'VE
DONE SO MUCH ON THE ELECTRIC
SIDE WE THINK ALL THAT'S
GREAT AND OR MEMBERS EMBRACE
THAT THIS IS JUST -- AVAILS
THE OPTION OF USING RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS AS LONG AS THAT
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS IS FROM
CALIFORNIA AND THE OFFSET IS
FROM CALIFORNIA THEY GIVE THEM
CREDIT UNDER THE INNOVATIVE
CRUDE -- ACCOUNTING METHOD
METHOD SYSTEM THAT'S A LONG WORD
NOT SO IT ALSO BY THE WAY HELPS
OUR MEMBERS BECAUSE THE MORE
OF A MARKET THERE IS FOR THIS
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS THE MORE
PEOPLE SEEK INTERCONNECTIONS
AND WE BELIEVE THAT'S GOOD FOR
OUR MEMBERSHIP AND WE BELIEVE
THAT MORE IN USE CUSTOMERS
FOR NOBLE NATURAL GAS IS GOOD
FOR THE STATE IN A CERTAINLY
GOOD FOR ALL INDUSTRY AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE SUPPORT THANK
AND OTHER SPEAKERS IN FAVOR
MISTER CHAIRMAN GOOD AFTERNOON
P. ANTHONY THOMAS RIPPING IN
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION -- THE
-- CFS PROGRAM OF COURSE IS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND THAT
WAS THAT WAS OF COURSE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE -- UNDER BROAD
AUTHORITY TO GIVE IN THE CAR --
AND THIS LEGISLATURE BY A. B.
THIRTY TWO -- BY REPLACING
THE USE OF FOSSIL FUEL NATURAL
GAS WITH RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS ARE ORANGEY -- THE
PROCESS BECOMES LESS CARBON
INTENSIVE CONSISTENT WITH THE
GOALS OF THE LC FS IN PLEASE
HAS THE -- ANALYSIS POINTS
OUT MISTER CHAIRMAN THE CARD
IS TO JUST CONSIDER THE USAGE
OF THIS JUST TO CONSIDER DOES
NOT SAY SHALL DOES NOT SAY MADE
DOES NOT SAY WELL IT'S JUST TO
CONSIDER IT -- THIS BILL THAT
YOU KNOW WAS PASSED -- POP THE
SIM BEFORE WHICH SIXTY TO VOTE
NO VOTE NO -- NO OPPOSITION
VOTE AND APPROPRIATIONS AS
WELL SO WE THINK IT'S A GOOD
WAY TO MEET THE AGGRESSIVE
GOALS OF REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND LITERATURE YES
VOTE ON THE BILL THANK YOU
OKAY -- ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS IN FAVOR
PLEASE COME FORWARD WE
HAVE SPEAKERS IN FAVOR
WE HAVE ONE IS THE RETURN
CAL CHAMBER IN SUPPORT OKAY
HOW ABOUT OPPONENTS ANY
OPPONENTS STORE TO TESTIFY
AGAINST THE BILL THE BILL
OKAY WE ARE MOTION AND
-- YOU HAVE A CLOSE
YOU HAVE A CLOSE YOUR I'M
SORRY A CLOSE A GAS FURNACE
OKAY THANK YOU THAT'S
OKAY CHOLERA PLACE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CENTER ABOUT I FELT
AYE BATES AYE BATES AYE DOLLY
DON GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
MCGUIRE MORALE ROTH ROSS
I RUBIO RUBIO AYE SKINNER
STONE STONE AYE NUMBER WHAT
COUNTY WE HAVE SIX ROWS
OF A REALLY THE ROLE AS
A MEMBER YOU MISTER CHAIR
I TOLD THE
NUMBERS STREET IS BEEN
USED -- IN TWENTY THREE
MOVIES AND SHOWS TV SHOWS
ACCORDING VERTICAL -- WHAT WHICH
IS ONE OF MY FAVORITES THE WIND
-- THE LOVE BUG THE LOVE BUG ME
WAS USING THE LOW JADE
WHAT'S UP DOC THAT'S A GOOD
ONE THERE WERE THAT ONE BARBARA
STARR STERN AND DOCTOR GOAL
FOOT IN THE BEGINNING MACHINE IS
ALSO SO WE HAD QUITE A FEW
MOVIES AND -- I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT KIND OF TV SHOWS I'M SURE
CAGNEY AND LACEY YEARS ONE OF
THOSE SO WHAT WE'LL FIND OUT
WE'LL FIND OUT THE COMPLETE
LIST AND SEND IT OUT BUT
-- I'M -- VERY HAPPY
-- TO SEE THE TWENTY THREE
MOVIES WHICH IS PROBABLY
WHY LUMBER C. SO CROWDED AS
AS AS WE SAW FOR THE
BILL WAS NEEDED SO OKAY
-- WE WILL --
-- GO THROUGH THE BILLS
AND CALL THE ROLL ON THE
BILL'S ONCE AND THEN CALL
FOR MEMBERS TO COME AND VOTE
AND -- ITEM SEVENTEEN
IS A TO YOUR BILL THE
ALTURAS HOLD ITEM SEVENTEEN
AND MADE IT TO YOUR BILL
AND -- WE WILL SEE THAT IN THE
BILL COME TO THE COMMITTEE IN
JANUARY OKAY IT'LL BE A TO
YOUR BILL SAVINGS ACCOUNTS TO
US IN JANUARY OKAY ITEM
SEVENTEEN SO -- -- WILL
CALL THE ROLL AND MAYBE TO
START WITH THE AND SECOND
-- PLEASE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS OF
FILE ITEMS ONE AND SEVEN CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE
DODD DODD AYE GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MORALE
HI MORRELL AYE ROSS ROSS
I RUBIO RUBIO AYE SKINNER
WE NOW HAVE ELEVEN VOTES ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE A FEW
MEMBERS COMING AND WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE WILL OPEN ON THAT SOLIS
NEXT ONCE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CENTER MCGUIRE SKINNER
STONE WHAT CASTING
AS IN THE BILL THREE SEVENTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SENATOR GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE MORALE
MORRELL AYE ROSS ROSS I
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SKINNER
THOSE ELEVEN VOTES IN FAVOR
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL FOR
FORTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SENATE REQUIRE STONE
TURN THOSE IN FAVOR
FOR ITEM FOR FORTY
NINE SKINNER SKINNER
SO ITS TO TEN ZERO ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN OH EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CENTER BATES
DOLLY GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE MCGUIRE SKINNER
NUMBER BUT ASKING
THANK FIVE VOTES IN FAVOR
WITH THE ROLE TO FRESHEN
MEMBERS THIS IS THE SENATE
BILL SEVEN FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SENATE MCGUIRE
SKINNER AMBERG CASKEY
NINETY NINE VOTES IN FAVOR ON
A BILL LEADER OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THIS IS THE SENATE BILL
EIGHT THIRTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE SUMMER
WIRE SKINNER NUMBER
NUMBER NINE
RUN THE LACKEY BILL
I NUMBER I WILL CASKEY
TEN ZERO BILL TEN VOTES IN
FAVOR WILL LEAVE THE ROPE
FOR US IN MEMBERS THIS IS
THE ONLY REAL TEN TWENTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CENTER BATES
GILL BATES NOW GALGIANI
IT WAS RUN ITEM TO
MCGUIRE SKINNER
AMBER HI AMBER I WAS ASKING
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN
VOTES IN FAVOR
THIS IS THE LEVEL TEN FORTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CENTER
BATES NO NO DODD
DODD AYE MCGUIRE
MORALES MORALE NO RUBIO
THEY ACCEPTED YES
YES RUBIO AYE SKINNER
NUMBER I WOULD COUNTY
SIX SIX
EIGHT SIX SIX FOUR SIX
TO FOR THAT LEADER OPEN BRONSON
MEMBERS ON A BILL THIS IS
EXTRA FOR THIS IS THE
SENATE BILL ELEVEN HUNDRED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER COME
LONGER DONE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS CENTER DOLLY
I DOLLY AYE DODD
DODD AYE MCGUIRE MORALE
NO RUBIO
THE BILL I SKINNER AMBER
AMBER I WITH CASSIE
EIGHT VOTES IN FAVOR WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE AFTER MEMBERS
HE VOTES IN FAVOR THIS IS
EMILY BELL A LEVIN NINETY FIVE
BISON REMEMBER O'DONNELL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE SIR
DOLLY DOLLY I DON
DODD AYE MCGUIRE MORALE
WELL I SKINNER NUMBER
FIVE I'M BURKE I WOULD COUNTIES
TEN TWENTY ZERO LEADER OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THIS
IS THE SENATE BILL TWELVE
TWENTY SIX FIRES IN THE MEMBER
HOLDEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CENTER DOLLY
DODD DODD AYE
GALGIANI MCGUIRE
ROSS ROSS I RUBIO
RUBIO AYE SKINNER
THREE SEVEN VOTES IN FAVOR
LEAVE THE ROLE FOR PRESS MEMBERS
THIS ISN'T ABOUT THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CENTER MCGUIRE SKINNER
AMBER HI AMBER I WOULD COUNTY
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
OH FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING OF THE MOTION AS DO
PASS SENATE DALI DALI
NO DODD DODD AYE MCGUIRE
MORALE MORALE NO RUBIO
RUBIO I SKINNER NUMBER
WE CASTING
FIVE VOTES IN FAVOR LEAVE THE
ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
THE ANSWER ITEM SEVENTEEN
IS BEEN MADE IT TO
YOUR BILL AT SERVE
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
SO WE'LL WAIT TILL
THE REMAINING MEMBERS
COM AND -- POOL
OPEN THE ROLE
I THINK
WE HAVE
WE HAVE SOME MEMBERS AND OTHER
COMMITTEES WILL WAIT FOR THEIR
ATTENDANCE AND CALL THE ROLL
WELL LIFT WITH THE CALL ON
THE BILLS AND WE'LL GO THROUGH
THE BILLS ONE MORE TIME
AND CLOSE THE ROLE SO WILL
CALL THE ROLL ON THE REMAINING
BILLS I THINK WE'LL START
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AND CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE
ITEMS ONE AND SEVEN CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VICE CHAIR VOTING I
CENTER MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
SKINNER ALL RIGHT SKINNER HI
THIRTEEN TO ZERO THAT'S HOUSES
THIS IS A LEVEL TWENTY NINE BASE
IN THE MEMBER HOLDEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CENTER MCGUIRE I SKINNER
INNER AYE STONE WHAT
CASSIE I WOULD ASK THE I TWO
ZERO TWELVE TO ZERO
THIS IS OUR SERVICES THIS IS
A FAMILY ROOM THREE SEVENTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CENTER MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER I
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN TWO ZERO
THEIR MOTION PASSES THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FOR FORTY NINE
BASE IN THE MEMBER GALLAGHER
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CENTER MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
TWELVE TO ONE
-- THAT MOTION PASSES THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN OH
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
BATES DALI DALI I
MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER
SKINNER AYE AMBERG I'M BURKE
I WAS HAPPY BECAUSE HE AYE
AND TEN THE US
TEN VOTES -- THAT
MOTION CARES PASSES
THIS IS THE SENATE BILL SEVEN
FIFTY NINE BY SOME THE MEMBER
BIGELOW THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE SENATE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER
SKINNER AYE AMBER NUMBER
I WILL CASKEY BECAUSE HE I
THIRTEEN TO ZERO THE MOTION
CARRIES THIS IS THE MOBILE
EIGHT THIRTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER SKINNER
I WILL CASKEY BECAUSE HE AYE
THIRTEEN TO ZERO THE MOTION
CARRIES THIS IS A SIMILAR
BILL TEN TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE SENATE MCGUIRE
WHERE I SKINNER I
WILL COST ME WITHOUT THE AYE
TWENTY THREE THAT'S TEN VOTES
IN FAVOR OF THE MOTION CARRIES
THIS IS A SENSIBLE TEN FORTY
SIX FIGHTS IN THE MEMBER TING
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CENTER MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE I SKINNER
I WILL COUNTY BECAUSE HE I
NINE VOTES IN FAVOR OF THE
MOTION CARRIES THIS IS A SIMPLY
BILL ELEVEN HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CLOGGING KAMLAGER-DOVE
OF THE MOTION IS DO PASS
SENATOR MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
SKINNER SKINNER I WILL COUNTY
SEVEN IN FAVOR OF THE MOTION
CARRIES A WEAPON OR EXCUSE ME
PARDON ME CORRECTION ELEVEN
VOTES IN FAVOR OF THE MOTION
CARRIES THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN NINETY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SENATE REQUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
SKINNER SKINNER HI WITHOUT
SKI I BECAUSE HE AYE THIRTEEN
ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO EMOTION
CARES THIS IS IN THE BILL TWELVE
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE DOLLY MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER SKINNER HI
NINE VOTES IN FAVOR OF THE
MOTION CARRIES NINE VOTES
PASSES THIS IS THE SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CENTER MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
SKINNER I'M SORRY THIS IS
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE THIRTY
WHERE I WANNA BUY SKINNER
AYE WITHOUT SKI -- CASKEY I
THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN VOTES
IN FAVOR OF THE MOTION CARRIES
THIS IS THE SENATE BILL SIXTEEN
OH FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING THE MOTION AS DO PASS
CENTER MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE
AMBERG CASKEY WORK HOURS
BUT I CAN'T SEE AYE
THE LIST OF CRICKETERS NO HE
DID NOT FINDING WHAT WAS
WHICH EIGHT TO WEAR EIGHT
VOTES IN FAVOR THE MOTION
CARRIES -- ITEM SEVENTEEN
WAS MADE A TO YOUR BILL
OKAY THE FUTURE HAPPY
ANNIVERSARY THANK YOU
FOR HEARING HEALTH BIG
BIG ANNIVERSARY TODAY
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED